l'état monsieur saumon pour une mise au
point de sujet d'un vote
oui pour une rectification de vote
effectivement c'était marqué je n'ai pas
pris par au vote mais en fait je voté
pour parce qu'il n'y a pas eu une bonne
transmission
ou dans le scrutin numéro 3 précédent
au point monsieur saumon elle sera
publié au Journal officiel et figurant
dans l'analyse politique du scrutin
concerné
l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion de
la proposition de loi visant à la
consolidation et à la
professionnalisation de la formation des
internes en médecine générale afin de
lutter contre les déserts médicaux
présentés par Monsieur Bruno Retailleau
et plusieurs de ses collègues demandent
du groupe les républicains dans la
discussion générale la parole est à
Monsieur Bruno Retailleau auteur de la
proposition de loi
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je voudrais
saluer bien sûr la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales
Catherine Deroche et puis l'excellente
rapporteur Corinne Humbert qui a fait un
excellent travail monsieur le ministre
la France est aujourd'hui le pays des
pénuries et des rationnements pas
seulement pour le carburant ou
l'électricité pas seulement sur un
certain nombre de produits alimentaires
cher Laurent Duplomb mais aussi sur des
médicaments et malheureusement sur
l'accès aux soins cette situation c'est
plus qu'un problème cette situation
c'est une formidable injustice
pour des millions de nos compatriotes 6
millions 300 000 françaises et français
mais c'est même plus qu'une injustice
c'est un scandale c'est un scandale
quand on met ce chiffre de Français qui
n'ont pas accès à un médecin traitant
à la dépense que nous avons pour la
santé dans notre pays et qu'on la
compare cette dépense notamment au pays
de l'OCDE parce qu'il est très élevé
d'où vient d'où vient si j'ose dire ce
scandale certainement pas des médecins
ça n'est pas leur faute
cette situation procède de choix qui ont
été des choix
technocratiques et des choix
idéologiques d'abord des choix
technocratiques puisque on a abandonné
la médecine et la santé aux mains de
comptable et de technocrates et on a
pensé à l'époque il suffirait pour
ralentir les dépenses de santé de
rationner l'accès aux médecins et de
former de moins en moins de médecins
le choix idéologique c'est d'avoir tout
misé sur une organisation très hospitale
au centre de notre système de santé ce
qui fait que la médecine libérale a été
mise à mal et ce qui fait que aussi la
formation de nos jeunes médecins a été
très orienté dans justement les facultés
de médecine sur autre chose que leur
installation en médecine générale la
médecine générale en réalité a subi ces
deux influences qui l'ont finalement
extrêmement fragilisé et bien le moment
il est venu monsieur monsieur le
ministre mais mes chers collègues dit
remédier d'y remédier parce que cette
conséquence elle est français qui la
supportent mais c'est aussi les élus
locaux ce que je suis venu dire à cette
tribune c'est que beaucoup de maires
d'entreflu parce que évidemment ils sont
en première ligne et la population leur
population dans un village dans une
petite ville dans une grande ville la
population rend les mers responsables
alors que ils ont rivalisé d'un certain
nombre de propositions alors même
jusqu'à salarié des médecins ouvrir bien
sûr des maisons de santé nous avons fait
aussi avec votre appui du reste des
centres de soins non programmés la
situation n'est plus possible nous ne
voulons plus désormais laisser les mères
laisser nos compatriotes seul avec ce
problème ou nous agissons ou nous
agissons pas c'est ce que propose
justement cette PPL pourquoi on en est
arrivé là et pourquoi les solutions qui
sont actuellement mises en place il y en
a d'ailleurs et je pense que il n'y a
pas de panacée et qu'on arrivera pas à
trouver la seule unique et bonne
solution j'en suis certain il y a un
bouquet de solutions mais pardon les
solutions qui sont aujourd'hui en place
sont des solutions insuffisantes le
déblocage du numéro exclusus pardon
beaucoup de facultés quand on parle des
doyens n'ont pas les moyens en réalité
de former ces nouveaux médecins et puis
ensuite ça met 10 ans plus combien
d'années d'installations
alors on va attendre on va attendre mes
chers collègues disant 15 ans non on
peut plus attendre c'est pas possible il
y a d'autres solutions des aides y
compris des aides des collectivités des
aides bien sûr de l'État mais ces aides
elles viennent trop tardivement c'est
pas d'ailleurs ce que demandait médecin
c'est pas
c'est juste une rustine mais c'est pas
une réponse fondamentalement
satisfaisante alors je sais qu'entre un
certain nombre de collègues y compris au
sein d'un certain nombre de groupes
certains voudraient la coercition je me
souviens d'un excellent rapport d'un
collègue de l'Union centriste Jean-Marie
versenberg qui nous avait fait un point
sur ce que donnait sur les résultats de
la coercition sélective du
conventionnement sélectif notamment en
Allemagne j'invite les uns les autres à
pouvoir en relire les conclusions les
conclusions c'était que en réalité ça
fait réguler un petit peu et encore les
zones surdenses et ça n'avait rien fait
en zone soudance et chaque et mat et je
crois que on en conviendra donc me
semble-t-il la solution n'est pas celle
de la coercition ça n'est pas non plus
la solution de palliative telle que
j'expliquais sur les aides qui existent
déjà parce que elles ne produisent pas
suffisamment de résultats la solution
elle est quelque part curative c'est ce
que nous essayons de creuser nous avons
essayé de faire les propositions pour ne
pas rester les bras ballants pour ne pas
laisser encore une fois ni nos
compatriotes ni les maires de France
seuls face à ce problème cette solution
elle nous a été aussi inspirée par le
fait que le gouvernement puisque dans la
loi Buzet en 2019 nous avions voté vous
savez les chers collègues les six mois
de dernière année du troisième cycle de
médecine générale comme étant six mois
que les jeunes médecins devaient faire
sur le terrain jamais jamais de gauche
et de droite vous pourrez je pars sur
votre contrôle jamais le décret n'a été
pris pourquoi j'avais le décret a été
pris parce qu'on nous expliquait ben
faut pas déshabiller Paul pour habiller
Jacques parce que il faut laisser les
internes de l'hôpital donc si vous
voulez nous on a creusé on a creusé
encore une fois nous voulions des
propositions et nous vous proposons
cette proposition ce texte là qui est un
texte qui est important pour nous
puisqu'il s'agit de créer une quatrième
année de consolidation de
professionnalisation au troisième siècle
de médecine générale ça permet un
d'installer provisoirement certes mais
3500 à 4000 jeunes médecins généraliste
sur l'ensemble de nos territoires en
ville ou en rurales parce que désormais
c'est la France entière qui est un vaste
désert médical ça leur permet d'être
rémunéré de façon attractive et nous
tenons beaucoup à les rémunérer comme de
vraiment médecins avec un paiement à
l'acte ça permettrait aussi aux
collectivités de s'engager beaucoup de
collectivités ne demanderait pas de
mieux que de leur mettre à disposition
par exemple un logement parce que la
question se posera quand on est pendant
une année sur un territoire c'est une
évidence et ça permettrait surtout aussi
de faire en sorte que on puisse
faciliter l'installation dans nos
territoires
urbains ou ruraux pour ces jeunes
médecins parce qu'on pense que la
formation actuelle ne les prédispose pas
ne les incite pas à s'installer quand on
lit d'ailleurs les auditions et le
rapport l'excellent rapport de notre
rapporteur oui bien sûr je vous fais pas
dire je constate d'ailleurs que il y a
peut-être pas l'unanimité mais il y a
quand même un consensus
si s'était établi j'avais moi-même
rencontré l'ordre national j'avais
rencontré les deux grands syndicats des
médecins généralistes et deux grands
syndicats des internes franchement
j'avais pas senti une frange opposition
donc je pense que la médecine générale
les internes sont les seuls à ne pas
avoir cette quatrième année de
consolidation depuis que cette médecine
générale est devenue une spécialité et
on pense que là il y a un problème et
que cette année de consolidation
permettrait d'avoir une meilleure
préparation une meilleure incitation à
l'installation de ces jeunes médecins à
condition qu'on les accompagne je dis
bien entendu qu'il faut un médecin
référent c'est un point que
il est important en tout cas de
souligner et puis ensuite de mettre
effectivement en
œuvre ce que je voudrais dire pour
terminer c'est une proposition qui est
importante j'ai vu que et nous avons vu
vous m'aviez d'ailleurs appelé que vous
l'avez en quelque sorte reprise dans le
pvfss je pense que vous l'avez fait de
façon précipitée sans beaucoup de
concertation et sans en définir les
modalités ce qui a pu je pense réduire
un certain nombre de syndicats notamment
d'interne je pense aussi que la façon
dont elle a été rédigée vous fait courir
le risque d'une disposition
anticonstitutionnelle dans la mesure où
elle n’importe pas vraiment les finances
de la sécurité sociale peu importe cette
en quelque sorte cette proposition de
loi est une séance de rattrapage et je
suis très heureux de pouvoir y
contribuer
utilement je pense mes chers collègues
que quand on choisit je sais qu'un
certain nombre ont choisi parmi vous ce
métier quand on choisit de devenir
médecin on fait plus que choisir un
métier monsieur le ministre vous êtes
médecin on choisit non pas seulement une
vocation mais une mission de service
public et je pense que c'est aussi au
regard de cette mission de service
public que nous devons examiner cette
proposition de loi j'y crois beaucoup et
je pense que ça nous oblige nous à
parlementaire à bouger
à voter à faire des propositions ça vous
oblige vous l'exécutif aussi consolider
ces propositions et ça oblige quelque
part les jeunes médecins quand ils
s'investissent dans ce beau métier a
considéré que on peut pas laisser des
millions de Français vraiment sans
médecin traitant c'est une prise de
responsabilité nous la prenons
aujourd'hui nous l'apprenons je pense
avec une forme de courage avec beaucoup
de sincérité vous devez la prendre aussi
et le monde le milieu médical évidemment
doit la prendre je pense que c'est
fondamental il y a cette réforme elle
est à la fois elle est nécessaire et je
crois aussi qu'elle est urgente merci de
votre attention
[Applaudissements]
merci merci monsieur le Président
Retailleau et la parole est maintenant à
Corinne Imbert rapporteur de la
commission des affaires sociales
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales mes
chers collègues déposez par le président
l'excellent président Bruno Retailleau
et inscrite alors du jour à la demande
du groupe les républicains la
proposition de loi que nous examinons
cet après-midi poursuit deux objectifs
auxquels la commission des affaires
sociales a pleinement souscrit le texte
vise d'abord à améliorer la formation
des médecins généralistes en allongeant
d'un an le troisième cycle de cette
spécialité cette nouvelle année vous lui
professionnalisante doit permettre de
mieux accompagner les étudiants dans la
découverte de l'autonomie et de
l'exercice ambulatoire mais ce faisant
le texte vise également à trouver un
moyen d'action nouveau pour s'attaquer à
la problématique de l'accès aux soins et
j'y reviendrai
l'article unique de la proposition de
loi porte sur la durée du troisième
cycle des études de méthylle générale
elle le porte à 4 ans et affecte la
quatrième année à la réalisation d'un
stage en ambulatoire et en autonomie
supervisée
cette mesure est envisagée depuis
plusieurs années la durée du troisième
cycle de médecine générale restez fixé à
3 ans fait en effet figure d'exception
ceux des 43 autres spécialités
s'étendent tous sur 4 à 6 années elle
empêche la médecine générale de
bénéficier de l'ensemble des avancées de
la réforme du troisième cycle des études
de médecine intervenues en 2017 et
l'isole des autres spécialités ainsi les
futurs médecins généralistes sont les
seuls à ne pas bénéficier de la
troisième phase d'internat dite de
consolidation visant à consolider les
connaissances et compétences acquises
jusque là par les étudiants il ne
bénéficie pas non plus du statut de
docteur junior associé à cette dernière
phase et permettant aux étudiants de
réaliser pendant une année entière des
stages en autonomie progressives et
supervisées tout en bénéficiant d'une
meilleure rémunération
enfin alors que la soutenance de la
thèse d'exercices constituent désormais
l'une des conditions d'accès à la phase
de consolidation et donc souvent réalisé
dans les délais les étudiants de
médecine générale ne bénéficient pas de
cette incitation les retards de
soutenance sont fréquents et reportent
d'autant l'installation des jeunes
médecins généralistes
la durée du troisième cycle de métier
général est établi sur le minimum fixé
par l'Union européenne et s'avère plus
courte que celle retenue dans de
nombreux autres pays les médecins
généralistes suivent par exemple la
troisième cycle de 5 ans au Danemark en
Suède ou en Norvège
les enseignants et médecins que nous
avons auditionnés sont majoritairement
très favorables à cette mesure plusieurs
d'entre eux nous ont indiqué ils
travaillaient depuis plusieurs années
ils ont assisté sur l'opportunité
d'enrichir les référentiels de formation
la maquette actuelle ne comprend pas
suffisamment de stage en ambulatoire
alors que ce mode d'exercice constitue
un débouché naturel pour la médecine
générale
seuls prévus sont obligatoires réalisés
en ville son pourtant ces stages qui
préparent le mieux les étudiants à
l'exercice libéral en leur donnant une
expérience concrète du fonctionnement
d'un cabinet ou d'une structure
d'exercices coordonnées
la mise à jour de la maquette devrait
aussi permettre aux étudiants qui le
souhaitent d'approfondir plus facilement
des compétences spécifiques communes à
plusieurs spécialités
en améliorant la professionnalisation
des internes de médecine générale la
proposition de loi organise ainsi à
favoriser leur installation rapide
l'ajout d'une phase de consolidation
encouragera les étudiants à soutenir
leur thèse des issus de la troisième
année nous pourrons plus comme
aujourd'hui la reporter jusqu'à 3 ans
après la fin de leur internat surtout la
réalisation d'une année entière de stage
en ambulatoire et en autonomie
supervisée permettra d'améliorer
largement la professionnalisation des
étudiants et de mieux les préparer à
l'exercice en ville en elle-même
l'extension du troisième cycle porté par
le texte devrait donc être favorable à
l’amélioration de l'offre E2 soins
toutefois la proposition de loi ne
s'arrête pas là afin de répondre plus
directement au problème d'accès aux
soins dans de nombreux territoires et
donc très nombreux territoires elle
prévoit que les stages en ambulatoire de
4e année seront prioritairement réalisés
dans les zones soudainces identifiées
par les agences régionales de santé
cette mesure a concentré ces dernières
semaines les inquiétudes des
organisations représentatives des
internes qui ont craint que la formation
soit instrumentalisée pour régler les
difficultés d'action soin je tiens donc
à lever tout en biguïté prise en
Retailleau vient aussi de le rappeler le
texte que nous examinons aujourd'hui
n'entend pas sacrifier la qualité de
l'encadrement des étudiants ni celle de
leur formation au contraire il prévoit
que les stages de 4e année seront comme
les autres supervisés par des maîtres de
stage formés et agréés par l'université
ils devront permettre de mieux
accompagner les étudiants dans la
découverte de l'exercice ambulatoire et
l'appréhension progressive de
l'autonomie
afin de tenir compte des inquiétudes
manifestées par les organisations
d'étudiants et parce que l'expression
désert médical ne lui a pas paru
d'écrire finalement la réalité
contrastées il est vrai des zones
soudances la Commission a modifié
l'intitulé la proposition de loi afin de
mettre en valeur son objectif premier
l'amélioration de la formation des
internes en médecine générale malgré
tout je crois évidemment qu'il n'est pas
possible d'ignorer entièrement les
besoins de santé de nos territoires dans
l'affectation des internants stages
l'accès à un médecin généraliste
constitue un enjeu majeur pour nos
concitoyens en la démographie de la
profession est particulièrement
sinistrée la France a perdu en 10 ans
environ 5000 généralistes la diminution
de la densité médicale aggrave les
inégalités territoriales d'accès aux
soins la suppression du numérique
explosus et l'augmentation du
recrutement d'étudiants ne permettront
pas de résoudre cette situation avant
plusieurs années
c'est pourquoi je crois au contraire que
les affectations doivent être cohérentes
avec les besoins de santé des
territoires chaque fois que cela est
possible sans perte sur la qualité de
l'encadrement des étudiants afin
d'assurer la planification de cette
mesure les euphores devront être
poursuivis pour augmenter encore le
nombre de mètres de stage universitaires
et s'assurer que ceci mâle suffisamment
le territoire il s'agit d'un enjeu
central et bien identifié à ce titre des
collectivités territoriales sont déjà
employés à favoriser l'augmentation du
nombre de mètres de stage ces dernières
années en facilitant en accord avec les
facultés de médecine l'organisation des
formations de maîtrise de stage au plus
près du lieu d'exercices des médecins
généralistes
la condition de concilier ces deux
impératifs amélioration de la formation
des étudiants d'une part et amélioration
du service rendu à la population dans
les territoires d'autre part que la
réforme sera un succès ce texte est un
par indispensable en faveur d'une
meilleure réponse aux attentes de soins
de nos concitoyens il a deux mérite
celui de démystifier installation en
favorisant une meilleure connaissance de
l'exercice en cabinet mais également
celui de démystifier la notion de zone
soudanze il y a une vie dans ces
territoires mes chers collègues et vous
le savez tous
un deuxième motif d'inquiétude réside
dans la situation matérielle des
étudiants dans l'affectation serait
éloignée de leur domicile
les collectivités territoriales font
déjà beaucoup d'efforts dans ce domaine
je constate par ailleurs monsieur le
ministre que le Gouvernement a souhaité
ouvrir une concertation dans le cas
d'une mission interministérielle et
n'est pas fermée à l'idée de modalités
de rémunération spécifique à la médecine
générale je crois même que c'est
indispensable les docteurs junior quand
bien même ils exercent en autonomie
progressive sont aujourd'hui rémunérés
forment il faut le dire assez faiblement
au regard du travail qu'ils
accomplissent je souhaite comme le
président rotaïau que des solutions
puissent être trouvées pour étirer
justement les étudiants de médecine
générale qui suivront cette année
supplémentaire et leur permettent de
réaliser leur stage sans difficulté
matérielles il s'agit d'une condition
essentielle à la réussite de cette
réforme
enfin les organisations que nous avons
entendues nous ont tous confirmés que
l'ajout d'une quatrième année ne devrait
pas s'appliquer aux étudiants actuels du
troisième cycle de médecine générale
pour ne pas nuire à la cohérence de leur
formation la Commission a donc adopté un
amendement en ce sens prévoyant que le
dispositif ne s'appliquera qu'aux
étudiants qui a la date de la
publication du texte n'auront pas encore
débuté le troisième cycle cela ce délai
doit également permettre monsieur le
ministre de prendre le temps nécessaire
avec les parties prenantes pour établir
le nouveau référentiel de formation j'ai
pu constater lors de mes auditions que
la plupart d'entre elles y avaient déjà
beaucoup travaillé
vrai maintenant m'attarder sur le
contexte dans lequel intervient l'examen
de ce texte votre gouvernement a repris
monsieur le ministre l'essentiel sont
dispositif pour l'inclure au projet de
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale pour 2023 déposée sur le bureau
de l'Assemblée nationale le 26 septembre
dernier alors même que la proposition de
loi que nous examinons cet après-midi
était dépose au Sénat depuis janvier et
inscrite à son ordre du jour elle
s'inspire vous le reconnaîtrez
d'ailleurs de nos travaux
et comme l'a rappelé le président
Retailleau en effet nous avons adopté
dès 2019 les chers collègues à
dispositif qui prévoyait que les
étudiants de médecine générale réalisent
lors de leur troisième année d'internat
un stage d'une année en pratique
ambulatoire en autonomie supervisée en
priorité dans les zones soudances stage
qui a été ramené à au moins semestre à
l'issue de la CMP cette disposition n'a
jamais été appliquée par le gouvernement
qui n'a pas pris les décrets nécessaires
malgré les promesses données dans cette
hémicycle la proposition de loi reprend
aussi une recommandation du rapport de
la commission d'enquête relative à la
situation de l'hôpital qui proposait je
cite de renforcer la formation en
médecine générale par une quatrième
année d'internat en priorité dans une
zone sous dense je crois enfin que la
proposition de loi du président Bruno
retaille au constitue monsieur ministre
le véhicule le plus sûr pour adopter
cette mesure non pas seulement parce
qu'elle est antérieure au projet de loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale et
issue de nos travaux mais aussi parce
que l'article 23 du PLFSS qui porte
cette réforme n'est pas conforme à la
loi organique en l'absence
d'incidence financière de la mesure sur
les régimes obligatoires de base est mis
en évidence par l'étude d'impact établi
par le gouvernement lui-même c'est
pourquoi mes chers collègues je vous
propose d'adopter cette proposition de
loi elle constitue le meilleur moyen de
mettre en oeuvre cette quatrième année
qui permettra d'améliorer à la fois la
formation des étudiants de médecine
générale et surtout l'accès aux soins
dans nos territoires je vous remercie
merci Madame la rapporteur et maintenant
la parole est à Monsieur François Braun
ministre de la santé et de la prévention
monsieur le Président Madame la
Présidente de la Commission madame la
rapporteur mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs
je suis heureux d'être devant vous
aujourd'hui pour l'examen d'une
proposition de loi visant à la
consolidation et à la
professionnalisation de la formation des
internes en médecine générale
cette proposition de loi porte sur un
sujet qui me tient vous le savez très à
cœur à savoir la qualité de formation de
nos futurs médecins généralistes d'une
part et la lutte pour l'accès à la santé
dans l'ensemble du territoire d'autre
part
cette proposition qui fait écho à
l'article 23 du PLFSS pour 2023
actuellement en cours d'examen répondeur
donc à deux enjeux distincts
je parle bien dans jeu distincts car la
proposition gouvernementale qui fait
suite à un engagement de campagne du
président de la République ne vise en
aucun cas envoyer des internes en
médecine faire des stages dans des
territoires pour boucher les trous et ce
sans encadrement
elle vise au contraire par l’accession
au statut de docteur junior pour les
futurs médecins généralistes a renforcé
la formation des internes pour leur
permettre d'être en sortie de diplôme
autonome et plus à même de gérer une
installation un cabinet médical
c'est bien j'insiste là dessus
l'objectif premier de cette proposition
et si pour aider nos territoires nous
souhaitons en priorité envoyer ces
jeunes médecins vers les zones soudances
cela ne se fera aucunement au prix de la
qualité de l'encadrement à ce titre
cette séance d'examen législatif qui
nous réunit aujourd'hui est un moment
bienvenu pour nous permettre à quelques
jours du début d'examen du PLFSS en
séance publique de rappeler dans quel
cas de la proposition gouvernementale
s'inscrit
je remercie donc le président Bruno
Retailleau ainsi que l'ensemble des
sénatrices et sénateurs cosignataires de
cette proposition de loi de nous
permettre de débattre et d'échanger sur
cet enjeu crucial
la quatrième année d'internat de
médecine générale par d'un constat
ancien et partagé
sans la phase de consolidation qui
définit le statut de docteur junior
l'installation immédiate en sortie de
cursus n'est pas facile elle devient
même rarissime l'objectif de la mesure
gouvernementale et de la vôtre s'inscrit
dans le même état d'esprit si j'en juge
l'amendement de modification du titre de
la proposition de loi adoptée en
commission et donc d'améliorer la
formation des jeunes médecins tout en
facilitant leur installation à l'issue
de leurs études
non pas pour envoyer au front des jeunes
recrues mais pour parfaire une formation
polyvalente et exigeante
j'y tiens beaucoup cette quatrième année
de formation de professionnalisation
sera sortie d'un projet pédagogique
co-construit avec toutes les parties
prenantes dont les internes même
et concrétisera par des stages en
pratiquantulatoire auprès de maître de
stage universitaire expérimentés et
capable d'encadrer de transmettre leur
expérience et leur savoir-faire
je souhaite que cette réforme soit mise
en oeuvre dans les meilleures conditions
à cette fin nous avons lancé récemment
une mission avec la ministre de
l'Enseignement supérieur et de la
Recherche Sylvie retaillod cette mission
permettra avec l'appui de 4
professionnels de terrain reconnu de
conduire la concertation que requiert un
tel engagement dans en ce qui concerne
les dispositions de leur
hébergement vous en avez parlé mais
également les dispositions de leur
rémunération
comme le dispose l'article unique de la
proposition de loi nous souhaitons que
ces stages soient effectués en priorité
sans que cela ne soit une obligation
dans les zones soudainces afin aussi de
faire découvrir ce mode d'exercice au
futur médecin qui n'ont pas forcément eu
l'occasion d'y exercer dit suivre un
enseignement pendant le cours de leurs
études
les inégalités d'accès à la santé sont
intonables et nous devons agir
résolument contre elle
aujourd'hui vous l'avez dit monsieur le
Président 6 millions de Françaises et
Français restent 100 médecins traitant
parmi eux 600 000 personnes souffrent
d'une affection de longue durée cela
concerne les lycam également beaucoup de
nos concitoyens précaires ou vivant avec
un handicap cette situation n'est pas
acceptable surtout qu'elle est très
inégale selon les territoires
j'étais il y a deux semaines dans la
Sarthe pour le lancement du Conseil
national de la refondation en santé qui
a vocation à faire ce concerter
l'ensemble des partis prenantes du
secteur pour que nous trouvions
collectivement les solutions pour qu'il
n'y ait plus aucun laisser pour compte
en matière d'accès à la santé
là-bas pour ne citer que cet exemple le
nombre de médecins généralistes libéraux
et de 59% mille habitants bien en
dessous de la moyenne nationale de
85%.000
ce déficit de médecin généraliste
traitant dans certains territoires et
d'autant plus problématiques qu'ils
jouent un rôle essentiel de suivi de
proximité tout au long de la vie
nos médecins généralistes traitants sont
aussi les aiguilleurs de notre système
de santé puisqu'ils orientent les
patients et assurent la nécessaire
coordination de leur parcours de soins
surtout cette situation a des
conséquences sur l'ensemble du système
de santé la situation des urgences que
je connais bien qui sont devenus pour
beaucoup un premier recours le montre
puisque leur fréquentation a augmenté de
plus de 50% en 20 ans
mais lorsque tous s'organisent ville et
hôpital comme avec les mesures prises
cet été elle chute enfin pour la
première fois de 5%
nous devons par responsabilité à l'égard
de nos concitoyens prendre des mesures
fortes vous l'avez dit la création d'une
quatrième année d'internat de médecine
générale s'inscrit ainsi dans tout un
arsenal de mesure du PLFSS qui vise à
renforcer l'accès à la santé à travers
nos territoires
je pense par exemple à la création d'un
cadre plus adapté pour les négociations
conventionnelles qui devra nous
permettre de mettre en place des
engagements réciproques au service des
Français dans tous les territoires
notamment les moins dotés dans une
logique de droit et de devoir je pense
aussi à la simplification des aides pour
l'installation de nos médecins dans les
zones soudances pour intensifier leur
impact enfin je tiens à souligner le
fait que nous allons pouvoir tirer les
fruits dans les prochaines années des
réformes déjà engagées dans le
quinquennat précédent vous l'avez cité
la suppression d'une Méru clausus mais
qui effectivement n'aura des faits que
dans une dizaine d'années
cette réforme importante est nécessaire
que nous aurions dû prendre il y a 10 à
15 ans devrait permettre d'inverser la
dynamique de la démographie médicale et
de renforcer nos bataillons de médecins
généralistes comme spécialistes
mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs je le pense profondément cette
quatrième année ne serait pas seulement
une chance pour nos territoires sous de
thé c'est aussi une chance pour nos
jeunes médecins et infini pour les
patients oui cette année supplémentaire
leur permettra de bénéficier d'une phase
bienvenue de consolidation dans leur
formation à l'instar de ce qui est fait
dans les autres spécialités
c'est à mon sens la clé d'une mise en
responsabilité progressive et supervisée
vous l'avez dit pour accompagner le
mieux possible nos jeunes médecins
généralistes vers leur installation
elle traduit la volonté dès le début de
ma prise de fonction des solutions
concrètes et pragmatiques pour répondre
aux défis auxquels notre système de
santé fait face je partage donc avec les
auteurs de la proposition de loi le font
de ce qui est proposé
cependant comme vous le savez le
gouvernement a choisi de faire prospérer
cette mesure via le PLFSS pour 2023
c'est pourquoi le gouvernement apporte
un avis de sagesse bienveillante à la
proposition de loi du président
Retailleau je vous remercie
bien merci monsieur le ministre dans la
suite de la discussion générale
la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue Laurence Cohen pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen
écologiste pour 5 minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues la
proposition de loi du groupe les
républicains visant la formation des
internes en médecine générale permet
d'avoir un débat sur les réponses
publiques à apporter face aux
difficultés d'accès aux soins merci à la
rapporteur Corinne Imbert pour son
travail comment accepter en effet que
30% de la population française vit dans
un désert médical la difficulté pour
prendre un rendez-vous avec un
généraliste en secteur 1 n'est plus une
situation spécifique au territoire
ruraux elle concerne désormais également
les territoires périurbains et urbains
ainsi la région Île-de-France et le 1er
désert médical de France
62,4% de la population francilienne soit
7,6 millions de personnes ont du mal à
accéder à des médecins trop peu nombreux
les mères sont soumis à rue des profs
pour trouver une solution coûte que
coûte il faut redire que depuis 20 ans
les gouvernements successifs ont refusé
de supprimer le numerus clausus et
d'augmenter le nombre d'étudiants et
étudiants en médecine l'ancienne
ministre de la Santé Agnès Buzyn
reconnaît elle-même dans une tribune du
journal Le Monde que le numerus clausus
avait été desserré de façon trop
progressive et que je cite on a perdu
plus de 15 ans depuis 2017 le
gouvernement d'Emmanuel Macron n'a
pourtant pas corrigé la tendance puisque
le remplacement du numerus clausus par
le numerus apertus n'a pas
signifiéativement augmenter le nombre de
médecins formés faute de moyens
financiers et humains supplémentaires
pour les universités le nombre
d'étudiants et d'étudiants en médecine
est passé de 9300-2020 à seulement 11180
en 2021 alors que les besoins sont plus
importants la population plus nombreuse
les patients plus âgés et souvent
atteints de polypathologies dans ce
contexte la proposition de loi du groupe
les républicains d'ajouter une quatrième
année pour les internes en médecine non
seulement ne résoudra rien mais au
contraire va démotiver et précariser les
internes tout d'abord sur la méthode
l'ajout d'une dixième année d'études
sans avoir ouvert de négociations avec
les internes revient à mettre la charrue
avant les bœufs une réforme de la
formation des internes nécessiterait de
discuter du contenu pédagogique et du
rythme des études de réfléchir à la
prise en compte de l'épuisement
professionnel qui touchent les deux
tiers des internes à la revalorisation
de leur statut aux mesures pour lutter
contre les comportements sexistes lors
des stages dénoncés par l'association
des étudiants de médecine je veux
rappeler ici qu'un interne environ trois
fois plus de risques se suicider qu'un
jeune du même âge et qu'en 2021 il y
avait eu une campagne protège ton
interne alors ajouter une dixième année
d'étude prouve bien que cette
proposition de loi est en déconnexion
totale avec la réalité des internes
d'autant qu'elle ne réglera ni la
pénurie des médecins ni l'aspiration des
jeunes des jeunes médecins qui
souhaitent à juste titre pouvoir
pratiquer la médecine en conciliant
davantage leur vie familiale et
personnelle aujourd'hui la majorité des
nouveaux médecins inspire à exercer leur
activité profiter de manière salariée en
équipe et dans un territoire muni d'un
hôpital de proximité et non pas en
libéral comme le privilégie cette PPL il
faudrait donc favoriser la réalisation
de stage et l'installation dans les
centres de santé l'incitation effectuée
des stages dans les territoires sous
dotés ne va pas entraîner mécaniquement
l'arrivée de 3900 internes dans les
déserts médicaux les incitations
fiscales à l'installation ont démontré
leur limite puisque seulement 400
médecins par an sollicitent les 50 000
euros proposés pour s'installer dans un
territoire soudoté les internes qui
souhaiteraient effectuer un stage dans
un désert médical devront être encadrés
par un médecin senior alors que par
définition les déserts médicaux sont
dépourvus de médecins ou pour le moins
manque de médecin disponible de plus
l'ajout d'une année supplémentaire en
stage va créer une année blanche
d'installation de nouveaux médecins
enfin les critères d'attractivité pour
les jeunes médecins sont cruellement
défauts puisque les politiques
d'austérité menées ces dernières
quelques années y compris par la droite
mon cher collègue Bruno retaillod ont
entraîné la fermeture des hôpitaux et
maternités de proximité et la
disparition des services publics de
proximité selon nous la réponse
politique et multiple mais dans le temps
qui m'est imparti je vais privilégier
quatre propositions qui me semblent
majeures l'augmentation des moyens des
universités pour former davantage de
professionnels de santé le développement
descente de santé le rétablissement de
la permanence médicale de nuit et le
week-end en abrogeant le décret Mattei
et en revalorisation les gardes de tous
les soignants dans le public comme dans
le privé mise en place la
conventionnellement sélective dans les
zones surdotées mes chers collègues vous
êtes loin du compte avec votre PPL aussi
les sénatrices et sénateurs du groupe
communiste républicains citoyen
écologiste voteront contre cette
proposition de loi tout comme nous
voterons contre l'article 23 du PLFSS
monsieur le ministre qui prévoit le même
dispositif je vous remercie
bien merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant à notre collègue Nadia solo
goub pour le groupe Union centriste
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame la président de la
commission madame la rapporteur mes
chers collègues il y a quelques semaines
nous a été soumise une proposition de
loi visant je cite à la consolidation et
à la professionnalisation de la
formation des interlan en médecine
générale afin de lutter contre les
desserts médicaux les internes en
médecine générale n'étant pas une
variable d'ajustement les démarches qui
consisteraient à proposer une
modification de leur formation
uniquement dans le but de lutter contre
les déserts médicaux nous semblerait
inadaptés on en voit pas les jeunes dans
des déserts pour réparer des erreurs
dont ils ne sont pas responsables le
poids des mots ce n'est pas rien il est
grand temps d'en changer certains
j'habite moi même dans une région où
l'angoisse des patients et des soignants
est grandes l'accès aux soins est le
problème sans doute le régime d'un
sentiment d'abandon dramatiquement vécu
par les habitants et les électeurs on
ignorer l'attente des territoires les
travaux que nous avons menés avec Hervé
Moret et jean-françois-longjeau l'ont
démontré mais ce ne sont pas des déserts
de nouvelles manières de travailler il
amène de nouveaux habitants des projets
émergent des soignants ils viennent
aussi en nombre insuffisants hélas mais
de leur plein gré et avec un vrai projet
de vie les jeunes médecins ne
construisent pas leur vie pour des
primes ils construisent leur vie en
cherchant à s'épanouir
professionnellement et personnellement
donc pas de désert pas de punition en ce
et cela notre commission l'a bien
compris puisqu'elle a veillé à présenter
en séance une proposition de loi
désormais intitulée proposition de loi
visant à la consolidation et à la
professionnalisation de la formation des
internes en médecine générale si cette
initiative de Bruno Retailleau et nos
collègues est une proposition pour
orienter la formation des jeunes
praticiens vers plus d'ambibulatoires
alors c'est intéressant et ce doit être
soutenu les autres spécialités se font
en quatre années il y a une forme de
logique à aligner celle-ci considérée de
la médecine générale est une spécialité
pleine et entière exigeant une phase
longue de pratique de terrain qui est au
fond la meilleure des écoles une année
de docteur junior qui pour la rendre
pleinement attractive devrait être
assortie d'une juste rémunération un peu
comme certains d'entre vous l'ont sans
doute connu c'est moi ou années que
faisait les jeunes médecins généralistes
en remplacement ici et là le temps
d'écrire la thèse avant de se fixer pour
de bon
dans un communiqué d'un regroupement de
généraliste jeunes installés remplaçant
voici ce que je lis nous témoignons tout
notre soutien à nos futurs confrères en
formation nous réclamons pour une
formation de qualité et une phase de
consolidation qui les accompagne
réellement dans la construction de leurs
projets oui il est indispensable que
cette quatrième année soit une
plus-value pour eux dans le groupe Union
centriste les avis sur ce texte sont
majoritairement favorables si je le
voterai moi-même je sais que certains de
mes collègues émettent des réserves sur
le nombre potentiellement insuffisant de
mettre de stage sur la nécessité d'une
plus grande concertation sur le besoin
d'enseigner en médecine générale sur le
risque d'une coercition déguisée par le
passé comme conjoint collaborateur d'un
médecin généraliste j'ai accueilli
moi-même dans mon foyer de jeunes
internes en fin d'études pour des
sessions de quelques semaines je sais
combien ces séjours à ce moment-là de
leur vie à la découverte d'un territoire
au contact de ses habitants peuvent être
déterminants trois de ces stagiaires se
sont installés chez nous une année
pleine et entière en autonomie auraient
certainement eu des effets encore plus
significatifs donc j'y crois mais avec
des réserves cependant en effet quid des
maîtres de stage pour connaître les
médecins généralistes de la Nièvre donc
mon département et leur charge de
travail je sais que les sessions de
formation sur Dijon 2h30 de route aller
sur des journées entières qui reviennent
régulièrement c'est très dissuasif si
certaines sessions sont depuis la crise
sanitaire en distancielle celle qui
subsistent en présentiel doivent
absolument être organisés au plus près
des médecins dans tous les départements
comme cela commence à se pratiquer en de
rares endroits cette possibilité doit se
généraliser et c'est à ce prix que de
nouveaux maîtres de stage universitaires
viendront grossir les rangs actuellement
l'ambulatoire est déjà au programme du
des médecine générale mais il est
insuffisamment mis en oeuvre faute
parfois de lieux de stage et parfois
hélas parce que les internautes aussi
restent dans les CHU pour pallier les
manques de personnel c'est qui est tout
à fait inadmissible cette réflexion
autour de l'ambulatoire d'être et doit
être globale concernait également les
spécialistes ne pas rester théorique
s'inscrire peut-être dans un vaste
chantier de refonte des études médicales
en s'inspirant d'autres modèles voisins
reste l'épine au sujet du lieu de ces
stages puisqu'il est désormais à qui que
c'est presque tout le territoire
national qui est en zone sous dotée les
internes aiment les stages intéressants
mais enfin le cursus ils peuvent aussi
avoir des charges de famille et des
ancrages que l'on comprend aisément le
lieu de vie pendant une année entière
après de longues études ce n'est pas
rien l'idéal sera alors qu'il puisse se
diriger vers une région probablement
sous dotée aussi puisqu'elles le sont
presque toutes où ils ont peut-être déjà
une attache voire même un début de
projet quatrième année ne doit pas
impliquer territoire inconnu pas plus
que désert ou punitions il faut prévoir
de la souplesse dans les affectations ce
qui m'amène à un autre sujet essentiel
celui de l'origine géographique des
étudiants pour prendre encore le cas de
ma région si tous ceux qui réussissent
le concours de médecine à Dijon sont de
jeunes Dijonnais qui ont bénéficié d'une
prophyximité familiale et d'un contexte
connu et familier ils sont difficiles
sauf coercition de le venir les voir
s'installer en milieu rural c'est
pourquoi il est capital que les
formations se délocalisent ne se
contente pas aux grandes villes
universitaires et viennent au plus près
des territoires c'est en partie les
années pendant lesquelles nous n'avons
formé que de jeunes urbains que nous
payons actuellement une faculté de
médecine est en train de se mettre en
place à Orléans la passe santé première
année d'étude de médecine à Nevers
obtenu après de longues années de
bataille a permis à 50% des étudiants de
réussir le concours voilà une vraie
solution et il y en a d'autres en France
les déserts médicaux sont tout
simplement des déserts de formation il
en faut plus monsieur le ministre il
faut que le numerus aperçu mutant
numerus Proximus voilà ce que la
proposition de Bruno Retailleau m'a
permis d'exprimer si cette disposition
est votée alors il faudra que les moyens
soient là et le décret d'application
parce qu'il y a des précédents monsieur
le ministre vous partagez le même
objectif à l'article 23 du PLFSS
justifiant que la mesure aurait un
impact sur les dépenses des régimes
obligatoires de base ou sur les dépenses
des organismes concurrents à leur
doucement qui affecte directement
l'équilibre financier de ces régimes
toutefois au chapitre impact financier
global de l'étude d'impact votre
dispositif n'a aucun effet sur l'Europe
je ne doute pas de ce que je vois le
Conseil constitutionnel le verra aussi
aussi je vous invite à vous saisir de ce
véhicule législatif je termine en
reprenant une réponse du ministère à une
question que j'avais posée en 2019 sur
les stages des internautes en médecine
la ministre des solidarité de la santé
est extrêmement attaché à favoriser le
développement de la maîtrise de stage
ambulatoire les débats qui ont eu lieu
avant l'adoption de la loi du 24 juillet
2019 ont rappelé combien la
diversification des lieux de stage
constituent une nécessité pour permettre
aux étudiants futurs médecins de se
former et de découvrir un large spectre
de situation professionnelle alors
souhaitons que la loi de 2022 puisse
mettre en place en mieux ce que la loi
de 2019 n'avait pas vu aboutir je vous
remercie
merci merci chers collègues la parole
est maintenant à Stéphane Ravier pour
trois minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues bienvenue
en France le pays qui prétend posséder
le meilleur système de santé au monde
mais qui abandonne plus de 10% de sa
population soit 8 millions de personnes
dans les déserts médicaux même si
désormais certaines grandes villes se
trouvent sous dotées en raison
principalement de l'insécurité qui y
règne comme dans les quartiers nord de
Marseille où la passion telle ne manque
pourtant pas puisqu'elle vient des
quatre coins du monde et même plus
précisément du tiers-monde les déserts
médicaux se concentrent principalement
en ruralité le désert n'est pas que
médical il y est global comme on voulait
vous que médecin aille s'installer avec
sa famille dans un endroit où s'accumule
les problématiques de mobilité de
logements d'emploi ou dont on disparu
les écoles et les commerces faute d'une
véritable politique d'aménagement du
territoire de plus une aggradation
inéluctable de cet état de fête est à
venir un généraliste sur deux est âgé de
plus de 60 ans et partira bientôt à la
retraite le vieillissement général de la
population
se rendre l'abandon plus criant encore
les pénuries énergétiques et l'inflation
puisqu'ils ont ces phénomènes car
l'assurance maladie rembourse les
consultations mais pas les trajets pour
s'y rendre chez moi dans les
Bouches-du-Rhône la disparition de SOS
médecins dans les communes rurales à
pour conséquence moins de visite à
domicile et plus de médecins disponibles
les week-ends
sous tension les maires sont le dernier
influx nerveux d'une ruralité exsangue
beaucoup des blocs des aides incitatives
malgré cela les maisons de santé
pluridisciplinaire se retrouvent souvent
sans médecin face à une telle situation
c'est tout un panel de soutien à la
ruralité qu'il faut repenser mais avant
toute chose il faut réintégrer les
soignants non vaccinés leur suspension
qui était déjà un scandale mais vraiment
plus n'a vraiment plus aujourd'hui aucun
sens pour en venir au coeur de la PPL
les internes en médecine ne peuvent pas
être les variables d'ajustement les
carences de l'État ce sont déjà eux qui
font tourner l'hôpital en quatrième
année d'internat les étudiants ont entre
27 et 30 ans certains ont déjà fondé une
famille on ne peut pas leur imposer une
année supplémentaire après 10 ans
d'études sans qu'il sache où ils sont
affectés surtout en les payant 8 euros
par mois 8 euros à l'heure pardon c'est
déjà peu cette mesure coercitive sur un
homme pose également un problème de
suivi des passions où est chers
collègues retaillaux président
retaillaux
excellent président retaillaux comme le
veut la formule consacrée où est la
mission de service public que vous
évoquiez tout à l'heure pour justifier
votre texte un texte qui relève plutôt
de la philosophie macroniste un texte
que l'on retrouve d'ailleurs à les
savoir pourquoi dans l'article 23 du
projet de loi de finance de la sécurité
sociale présentée par le gouvernement
pour conclure je voterai contre cette
mesure palliative administrée à un
système en état de mort annoncé je suis
pour une partisan d'une réforme en
profondeur en faveur de la ruralité
aujourd'hui une méthode de demande à
être mieux exploitée celle du contrat
d'engagement du service public il aide
de les mettre ça à s'installer dans les
déserts médicaux à hauteur de 1200 € par
mois le nombre de ces signés l'évolution
chaque année et je conclus merci
monsieur le Président faisons en sorte
faisant en sorte que ce dispositif soit
plus connu en attendant ne reconstruire
la frativité de nos territoires
merci chers collègues et
la parole est désormais à notre collègue
Véronique Guillotin pour le groupe RDSE
merci
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame la Présidente de
commission madame la rapporteurs chers
collègues
cette proposition de loi l'initiative de
Bruno retaillod et d'un certain nombre
de ses collègues nous invite à nous
saisir de la question essentielle de la
formation des médecins elle doit
répondre à la fois à l'acquisition d'une
somme importante de connaissance d'un
savoir-être et surtout de la préparation
des jeunes médecins à leurs futurs
exercices professionnels qui pour les
généralistes se fera majoritairement sur
les territoires en libéral
la question n'est pas tant d'aligner le
nombre d'années de la spécialité
médecine générale sur celle des autres
spécialités mais plutôt et surtout de
savoir pourquoi on ajoute une troisième
une année supplémentaire une troisième
cycle d'études médicales s'il s'agit de
déployer un bataillon de docteur junior
sur des territoires sous dotés afin
d'apporter une réponse politique à la
problématique complexe des déserts
médicaux je n'y serai pas favorable car
en effet le doute persiste sur la
finalité de cette PPL du fait du titré
initial de la proposition de loi de la
commune de la communication qui a été
faite autour de cette mesure des
discussions qui ont eu lieu en
commission et en audition jusqu'à
l'exposer des motifs de la PPL qui
commence en évoquant la question des
déserts médicaux
alors que la discussion est entamée
depuis plusieurs années déjà sur cette
question que les étudiants professeurs
et doyens n'y étaient pas ils n'y sont
toujours pas fermement opposés la
finalité à peine masquée de cette mesure
a suscité beaucoup d'inquiétude
si l'accès aux soins doit mobiliser
chacun d'entre nous je ne crois pas aux
mesures de coercitive même en celles qui
se drap prêt de bonnes intentions et
d'autant plus dans un contexte de manque
de professionnels doit-on rappeler qu'en
disant la France a perdu 5000 médecins
généralistes qu'en 20 ans leur densité
sur les territoires abaissés deux fois
plus que celle des autres spécialités et
que 84% de notre pays est dit sous-doté
aucune réforme des crèmes mesure plan
non réglés ne règlerons de manière
isolée à elle seule la problématique de
l'accès aux soins tant le temps que le
nombre de médecins généralistes en
exercice n'aura pas augmenté de manière
significative par une amplification
nette du numerus à Perthus mais surtout
du nom du pourcent du quota de médecin
généraliste dans la sélection vers les
spécialités alors si cette année
supplémentaire doit avoir le jour ce
dont il faut parler c'est bien de
pédagogie de professionnalisation et
d'une meilleure adaptation de la
formation au cœur de métier de la
médecine générale
une quatrième année professionnalisante
bien pensée concerté pourrait devrait
mieux préparer les jeunes à la réalité
du métier qui se fait pour l'essentiel
je l'ai déjà dit en libéral et de fait
si elle est bien menée elle favorisera
les installations sur les territoires je
suis convaincue que cette quatrième
année avec un stage obligatoire en ville
mais aussi un stage libre dans un
hôpital de proximité par exemple
répondre à mieux aux exercices partagés
qui sont aujourd'hui plébiscitées par
les jeunes et aux décloisonnements ville
hôpital que l'on appelle tous de nos
vœux j'y vois aussi un autre avantage
les étudiants devront présenter leur
thèse en troisième année de troisième
cycle et ne pourront plus repousser
cette échéance qui les éloigne d'autant
d'une installation en cabinet mais cette
année supplémentaire doit répondre à
plusieurs conditions la première et
qu'elle ne doit pas être un prétexte
pour répondre de manière totalement
imparfaite
à la problématique des déserts médicaux
la seconde tient à l'adhésion des
étudiants du Collège national des
généralistes enseignants afin de les
emmener dans cette réforme et la
troisième et celle de l'encadrement s'il
est bien précisé que ces stages
s'effectueront sous un régime
d'autonomie supervisé il devrait être
obligatoirement encadré par un maître de
stage
et sur la question en avons-nous
aujourd'hui suffisamment on avait tous
suffisamment sur les territoires pour
pouvoir accueillir ces jeunes de 4e
année et enfin la rémunération la
proposition de loi évoque une
rémunération à l'acte cette option me
semble peu aboutie ne risquerait-elle
pas en fait de créer des conflits entre
stagiaires et référents ne faudrait-il
pas un socle commun salarial avec
pourquoi pas une incitation
supplémentaire dans le cas de cabinet à
forte activité ou dans le cas par
exemple une pratique en zone soudain de
manière générale n'oublions pas que ce
sont les bonnes conditions de travail et
ça a été dit par les orateurs précédents
un environnement professionnel stimulant
des territoires accueillants pour les
familles qui sont je le crois les
critères privilégiés du choix
d'installation des jeunes professionnels
plutôt que de dire orienter les docteurs
junior en priorité vers les territoires
soudés dont la définition reste
imparfaite ne pourrions-nous pas dire
orientons les en priorité vers des lieux
d'exercices où il existe des dynamiques
de santé des MSP des exercices
professionnel coordonnées des équipes de
soins primaires à même de leur donner
envie de poursuivre l'aventure et
faisons en sorte dès le début des études
médicales de former des jeunes des
jeunes médecins en proximité avec toutes
ces réserves le groupe RDSE nous a
priori pas défavorable à la proposition
de loi mais vous l'aurez compris pas un
emporte quel prix notre groupe
déterminera son vote en fonction de la
discussion qui va suivre et du sort qui
sera réservé aux amendements notamment
les plus coercitifs
merci chers collègues et la parole est
maintenant à madame la présidente
Catherine Deroche pour le groupe les
républicains pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame la rapporteur me chers
collègues je voudrais tout d'abord dire
que cette proposition de loi n'est pas
sortie du chapeau le président
Retailleau l'a dit en effet nous en
parlons depuis plusieurs années avec
avec et l'Ordre des médecins et des
doyens et lors de l'audition que nous
avions fait en début d'année notre
commission associant l'association des
étudiants en santé de France et la
conférence des doyens cette 4e année
avait été évoqué recueillant un
assortiment notamment de la conférence
des doyens je voudrais tout d'abord
remercier la rapporteur de la commission
des affaires sociales pour son travail
sur ce texte que j'avais bien évidemment
consigné et là en effet apporté deux
clarifications qui me semblent
indispensables sur l'entrée en vigueur
tout d'abord il est parfaitement clair
que l'allongement de la durée des études
ne s'appliquera pas aux étudiants qui
ont entamé leur troisième cycle la
réforme suppose d'une part une révision
de la maquette qui ne s'improvise pas et
d'autre part il ne s'agit de prendre au
dépourvu des internes déjà bien avancés
dans leur cursus deuxième précision
nécessaire il ne s'agit pas de réformer
les études de médecine générale pour
répondre uniquement à l'accès aux soins
dans des territoires soudains il s'agit
de réformer les études de médecine
générale pour consolider la formation
des futurs médecins en leur permettant
de se confronter au caractéristiques de
l'exercice en médecine de ville sous un
régime d'autonomie superficié la crainte
des étudiants nous l'avons entendu dès
2019 lorsque la Commission a proposé
d'aménager à l'époque la troisième année
du cursus pour permettre un an de venir
six mois en CMP six mois de stage en
autonomie supervisée il ne se sentait
pas prêt un exercice autonome craignait
pour la qualité de leur formation et
redouter une affectation forcée dans un
lieu non choisi abandonné à leur
solitude en des territoires dont le
terme même de désert usité fait parfois
sont leur une description peu engageante
rien de tel dans le texte que nous
proposons le modèle d'exercice est bien
celui de l'autonomie supervisée sur
l'autorité de mettre de stage
universitaire formé avec une formation à
l'exercice en ville et très certainement
à l'exercice coordonné avec le collectif
et la plus riprofessionnalité auquel
jeunes médecins aspirent la formation
premier recours en médecine de ville à
la gestion de l'entreprise médicale
entre guillemets qui fait actuellement
défaut ou à la compréhension des
mécanismes des projets territoriaux je
pense particulièrement au CPTs ou à
d'autres projets de ce qui viendront
compléter le cursus ce seront de vrais
apports pédagogiques pour les futurs
médecins nous n'allons pas tenter de
transformer de jeunes internes en
médecin de famille à l'ancienne ni
maître un médecin sous chaque clocher ça
c'était avant mais maintenant il en est
ainsi ce n'est plus la société actuelle
mais en revanche il faut il faut définir
pour les populations en difficulté
d'accès aux soins il faut réfléchir à
des formes qui peuvent évoluer dans les
territoires donnés réfléchir à des zones
d'activité médicale permettant un
équilibre permettant aux patients et aux
médecins un équilibre dans les demandes
de recours la concurrence entre les
territoires et délétères il nous faut
plus de coopération quant à
l'affectation forcée même si je conçois
bien que c'est le souhaite certains elle
ne me semble pas envisageable dans le
contexte de la démographie médicale
actuelle et du vieillissement de la
population que nous connaissons on ne
gère pas la pénurie par la coercition il
n'existe pas de zone surdité en tout cas
pas de zone surdotées en secteur 1 et
nos collègues l'adyssent à la fois un
phénomène
urbain Péru urbain ou rural en revanche
je pense et ce sera un des rôles de la
mission que vous allez mettre en place
monsieur le ministre je pense que la
mission devra associer les ARS les
UFR les représentants des internes les
ordres les ur et les élus et les élus
pour définir les zones et les lieux de
cette professionnalisation sur chaque
territoire avec ce temps de formation
nouveau ce dispositif crée du temps
médical supplémentaire et ça c'est
majeur en irriguant les territoires
chaque année de nouveaux médecins la
nouvelle maquette incitera les internes
en médecine générale à passer leur thèse
échéance qu'ils ont aujourd'hui trop
tendance à repousser ce qui est
rédhibitoire pour les installations et
ce qui dément un peu l'idée de de retard
à l'installation par cette quatrième
année les territoires ont un rôle à
jouer pour retourner le développement
pour soutenir le développement des
maîtres de stage universitaires cela a
été dit faire valoir leur dynamique et
mettre en place de bonnes conditions
d'accueil les collectivités sont déjà
très impliquées certaines obtiennent
d'excellents résultats il existe déjà
12000 mètres de stage universitaire
certes le nombre devra être renforcé
pour être
je sache universitaire pour un docteur
junior mais je pense que c'est tout à
fait possible bien sûr cette proposition
de loi ne serait constituée une réponse
unique au creux de la démographie
médicale auquel nous serons confrontés
pendant encore au moins 10 ans à cette
question est finalement complexe les
réponses doivent être multiples elles
vont de la télémédecine obligation de
tâches en passant par l'organisation de
transport d'accompagnement pour les
patients etc la liste n'est pas
exhaustive donc je pense que ce texte
propose en effet de préparer les
étudiants en médecine générale à la
médecine de ville afin qu'il fasse leur
choix de vie et d'exercice en confiance
et en pleine connaissance des
territoires où ils pourront faire le
choix de s'installer ce pari il faut le
prendre sans tarder dans un esprit
gagnant-gagnant c'est pourquoi bien
évidemment je voudrais ce texte
merci merci madame la Présidente et la
parole est maintenant à Daniel Chassin
pour le groupe Les Indépendants
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame la Présidente de la
Commission madame le rapporteur mes
chers collègues cette proposition de loi
du président Bruno Retailleau poursuit
un objectif que nous souhaitons tous
pour atteindre depuis maintenant une
décennie faire en sorte d'avoir des
médecins dans nos villages dans nos
Bourges bref lutter contre les zones
soudances et je sais que la commission
des affaires sociales est mobilisée sur
le sujet élu de la Corrèze médecin
améliorera le je ne peux que constater
les problèmes de manque dramatique de
médecins généralistes qui suivent en
rural ou en périphérie des villes les
citoyens doivent pouvoir être soignés et
suivi nous souhaitons avoir un médecin
dans nos maisons de santé j'avais déjà
déposé une PPL à ce sujet
la suppression du numérique clausus est
une bonne chose mais nous allons devoir
patienter une dizaine d'années avant
d'en ressortir les premiers effets sur
nos territoires actuellement nous allons
vers une catastrophe notamment dans les
territoires ruraux si nous ne prenons
pas rapidement des décisions efficaces
avec aussi des urgences encombrés car
cela a été dit beaucoup n'ont pas de
traitant la BPL que nous étudions
aujourd'hui propose une avancée nouvelle
c'est aussi une des promesses de
campagne du président Macron l'urgence
est réelle et je me réjouis que nous
ayons ce débat je félicite madame la
rapporteur colis Corinne Imbert j'ai
rencontré récemment des étudiants en
médecine qui m'ont fait part de leur
crainte ce qui ressort c'est le
sentiment d'être exploité avec une année
supplémentaire en étant payé 2000 euros
par mois après 10 ans d'études ce que je
conçois totalement auparavant vous savez
des remplacements s'effectuer en 6e ou
septième année les étudiants étudiants
en médecine
c'est suite à ces rencontres que j'ai
décidé de déposer trois amendements sur
cette PPL le premier il recevable
au-dessus de l'article 40 constitué d'un
amendement d'appels et je suis conscient
et qu'il n'aurait pas été adopté de
proposer une réécriture de l'article
unique et s'inscrivait dans la pensée
qui a dominé aux échanges en 2019 au
moment où la Loi relative et
l'organisation la transformation du
système de santé à l'époque je rappelle
que c'était un amendement consensuel de
la commission pour que les six derniers
mois d'Internet puissent se réaliser
dans les territoires où il y a un manque
de médecins
cela a été négocié par le président
Alain million avec les étudiants mais le
décret n'est pas apparu mon amendement
proposé que le stage de ça se passe soit
subi de notre stage de six mois faisant
passer à un an sans rajouter une année
supplémentaire complète à l'internat
médecine générale bien sûr à la priorité
donnée aux zones soudances de plus je
proposais une rémunération plus
importante de cette année de ça se passe
ce qui complétait mon amendement j'ai
déposé un deuxième qui lui aussi a été
déclaré et recevable pour les mêmes
raisons que le précédent pour lesquelles
je conserve un peu mon incompréhension
il portait sur la rémunération des
médecins junior dans le cadre d'une
quatrième année d'internat je porte je
proposais de placer cette rémunération
mensuelle à hauteur de l'équivalent de
10 consultations payées à l'acte par
jour avec un logement mais le médecin
qui fera appel à un message junior mais
aura une clientèle bien sûr très
important je appelle aussi que les
étudiants de dernière année d'internat
le professionnalisation ont déjà 9 ans
d'études ils sont formés ils peuvent
consulter seuls mais bien sûr avec
l'aide les conseils de médecins
référents médecins maître de stage
universitaire bien sûr c'est préférable
et c'est dans cette PPL mais Monsieur le
Ministre lorsqu'on a une clientèle
débordante les médecins n'ont pas le
temps d'être MSU voilà la réalité du
terrain et le médecin devra devenir
MSU avec plus de proximité dans la
formation enfin mon troisième amendement
porte sur le lieu de la dernière année
d'internat prévu dans la PPL je pense
qu'il est important qu'elle soit faite
dans le territoire de Chu ou l'étudiant
a fait ses études de même aussi que les
étudiants en quatrième et cinquième
année pourraient aller dans les hôpitaux
périphériques cela participe aussi à la
répartition géographique des étudiants
et des internes et à la découverte des
territoires monsieur le ministre non mes
chers collègues nous avons l'impériose
nécessité de proposer l'accès aux soins
dans tout nos territoires c'est le rôle
de l'État nous devons à mon sens
davantage écouter des sites étudiants en
ce qui concerne leur rémunération chez
Philippe le président le groupe les
années pendant votre a en faveur de
cette PPL qui j'espère apportera en 1900
en 2026 des solutions pour les zones
soudains merci
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant à notre collègue Raymonde
Poncet Monge pour le groupe écologiste
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame la rapporteur chers
collègues
signe de l'impuissance des politiques
publiques depuis longtemps les zones
soudances s'étendent renforçant les
inégalités d'accès aux soins selon
l'adresse entre 2015 et 2018 la part de
la population française vivant en zone
sous de thé en médecin généraliste a
augmenté de 50%. particulièrement
impactés les zones rurales et les zones
populaires
des métropoles subissent à la fois les
fermetures des hôpitaux de proximité des
maternités des services d'urgence et le
non remplacement des médecins des
infirmiers ou des sages-femmes en
domaine de dans le domaine de la santé
toujours selon l'adresse 60% des
personnes en territoire ruraux
connaissent des difficultés d'accès à un
médecin généraliste
comme souvent les mesures d'incitation
financières ont été privilégiées des
dizaines de millions ont été dépensés
avec des résultats plus que décevants la
Cour des comptes en 2014 puis en 2019
constate que ces mesures ont plutôt
provoqué des effets d'aubaine pour les
médecins déjà en place cet échec doit
nous conduire à reprendre l'analyse des
causes pour de nouvelles solutions
si certaines études scientifiques
disponibles concluent qu'un stage long
en zone rurale soudée surtout en fin de
cursus peu encourager les nouveaux
médecins à s'y installer beaucoup
estiment au contraire l'impact très
faible mais d'autres études pointent des
pistes intéressantes structurelles qui
ont donné d'excellents résultats
notamment à l'étranger et de plus des
résultats durables à ce sujet la
méta-analyse de l'adresse en 2021 est
formelle il ressortent de toute la
littérature scientifique que le choix de
s'installer dans une zone mal desservie
est en premier lieu lié à un ensemble de
facteurs personnels et ce sans
méconnaître d'autres conditions les
conditions d'environnement plus générale
intensité des services publics proximité
des centres hospitaliers autre
professionnel de santé installé sur ce
même territoire dynamisme des activités
économiques toutes ces raisons nous les
connaissons
de façon constante les travaux de
recherche conclu que l'origine rurale du
médecin est un facteur essentiel et le
meilleur prédicteur de l'installation en
zone rurale être né en milieu rural y
avoir grandi et avoir fait sa scolarité
ressortent dans tous les pays comme des
déterminants majeurs du choix d'exercer
dans cet environnement rural aussi
or les territoires ruraux étant
majoritairement populaire les élèves
issus de ces territoires se heurtent à
la sélection du à l'université amplifiée
depuis quelques années parcoursup
véritable machine de reproduction
sociale les études de santé comptent
parmi les plus clivés socialement après
les grandes après les grandes écoles
ainsi déjà sur représentés en études de
médecine les chances de réussite d'un
enfant de cadre métropolitain est
2,35
fois supérieur à celle d'un enfant
d'ouvrier cette absence de diversité
sociale a été amplifiée par les
politiques de déstructuration de
l'enseignement supérieur et la
concentration des lieux de formation les
fusions des universités vont à
l'encontre frontale des recommandations
de l'OMS
préconisant justement la
décentralisation des centres de
formation dans les territoires ruraux et
soudain
de nombreux pays ont entamé une démarche
de décentralisation des ressources à des
centres satellites ruraux voire ont
ouvert de nouvelles écoles de médecine
oui la Norvège l'Australie le Canada est
suivi ainsi les recommandations de l'OMS
de la critique des critères de sélection
à l'université pour ouvrir la
diversification sociale à la
décentralisation autant que possible des
lieux de formation certaines solutions
durables contre les déserts médicaux
réclament des mesures structurelles qui
questionnent les politiques tant en
matière d'enseignement supérieur que
d'aménagement du territoire
aménagement du territoire qui accentue
aujourd'hui un phénomène de répartition
sociale du territoire entre
concentration des cadres ce que le
chercheur Guillaume Faburel appelle les
classes créatives des cadres au sein des
grandes métropoles d'un côté et les
territoires ruraux majoritairement
ouvriers de l'autre qui subissent la
dévitalisation économique la fermeture
des services publics et des déserts
médicaux n'est pas étonnant dans ce cas
que le démographe Hervé Le Bras et puis
dire hier que la France des déserts
médicaux était celle des gilets jaunes
or pour lutter contre ce phénomène l'OMS
recommande des politiques ciblées pour
les étudiants d'origine rurale et
recommande de décentraliser une partie
des campus et des programmes d'internat
cette proposition de loi propose selon
nous une solution de régulation très
partiel et contestée en faisant
l'économie d'autres types de régulation
du moins de son débat notamment par
l'installation comme des causes que je
viens d'évoquer c'est pourquoi le groupe
écologiste va te raconter je vous
remercie
merci chers collègues et la parole est
maintenant à notre collègue Abdallah
Hassani pour le groupe RDPI
madame la Présidente
la proportion de loi que nous examinons
aujourd'hui est l'un des chemins de
recherche pour préserver et améliorer
notre système de soins surtout nos
territoires la médecine générale et la
seule spécialité en avoir que trois
années de formation en 3e cycle sans
phase de consolidation ni d'accès au
statut de docteur junior
le dispositif proposé vise à mettre en
place une quatrième année véritable
année de professionnalisation les
internes réaliseront plusieurs stages en
autonomie supervisée et un ambulatoire
tout en préparant mieux leur
installation longtemps mentionné comme
une pièce de réflexion pertinente cette
quatrième année permettrait l'arrivée
chaque année de plusieurs milliers de
médecins junior affectés en priorité
dans des zones où l'offre des soins est
faible
ce serait aussi l'opportunité pour ces
jeunes professionnels de découvrir et
apprécier d'autres lieux et d'autres
modes de vie
plusieurs véhicules législatifs nous
permettront de débattre davantage de
cette mesure le gouvernement Léa inscrit
dans le projet de loi de financement de
la sécurité sociale et je m'en félicite
nous sommes tous à la recherche de
solutions pour consolider la formation
de nos médecins faciliter leur
installation et également permettre à
chaque citoyen d'obtenir les soins qu'il
nécessitent sans inégalité la mesure
s'inscrit ainsi dans une logique plus
globale et effective d'amélioration de
la santé pour tous en complément
d'autres dispositifs déjà mis en oeuvre
par l'État et nos collectivités est
nécessitera
d'assurer un nombre suffisant de mettre
de stage grâce à l'effort engagé le
nombre de praticiens habilités a été en
hausse de 9,6% entre 2019 et 20
il faut inciter davantage les médecins à
candidater faciliter les procédures en
ciblant les territoires ou l’offre des
soins est très insuffisante un autre
exercice de médecine a changé de la
médecine a changé pardon les jeunes
professionnels ont désormais
des souhaits
qu'il faut prendre en compte si l'on
souhaite assurer leur Vénus sur nos
territoires et leur installation dans la
durée profession du conjoint éducation
des enfants service public sécurité mais
aussi organisations du travail en
lui-même existence d'un réseau de
paramédicaux et des spécialistes c'est
la suppose d'ailleurs
augmenter aussi le nombre des mètres de
stage universitaires dans les autres
spécialités tout un ensemble en fait
j'en suis d'autant plus persuadé que je
viens d'un territoire non pas non sous
doté mais
sous sous doté je dis bien sous doté et
j'aimerais d'ailleurs souligner le
travail réalisé par mes collègues de la
commission des affaires sociales sur le
système de soins à Mayotte l'offre des
soins en médecine de ville en
particulier et balbutiante 27 médecins
généralistes libéraux dont 7 mètres de
stage quasiment aucun spécialiste pour
300 000 habitants à la Réunion
le département voisin je viens collègue
de la Réunion qui était là
où la population est presse trois fois
supérieure il y a 1200 médecins généraux
et plus de 160 mètres 160 m de stage
Mayotte n'a pas de Chu
son centre hospitalier doit pas lier les
lacunes d'accès aux soins primaires
il est constamment sous tension et
multiplie les évacuations sanitaires
vers la réunion les maorilles qui en ont
les moyens vont se soigner hors du
département soit la réunion ou ici à
métropole
les autres renoncent souvent aux soins
même essentiels l'état de santé de la
population est très en dessin de la
moyenne nationale la sécurité sociale
est toujours régie par des dispositions
spécifiques mais je suis heureux de
constater que la convergence progresse
avec notamment
le projet de loi de finances
pour la sécurité sociale
c'est l'année prochaine l'extension à
Mayotte de la complémentaire santé
solidaire c'est vous savez que les
médecins libéraux souvent n'ont pas
signer de convention avec la sécurité
sociale donc ça pose beaucoup de
problèmes pour certains malades parce
qu'ils sont pas remboursés donc il reste
à la maison comme je l'ai dit un peu
plus haut cette quatrième année
d'internat apprendrez beaucoup aux
internes qu'il a fait chez nous et
serait une opportunité pour l'île je
vais souligner ici la création à
l'initiative du centre hospitalier de
Mayotte d'une agence territoriale de
recrutement qui a reçu cette année un
Grand Prix de l'Innovation
RH elle vise l'ensemble des acteurs de
santé du territoire centralisé le
recrutement accompagner les candidats
renforcés l'attractivité fidélisée là je
fais la campagne de l'hôpital les
obstacles sont dans nos territoires et
ils le sont de façon d'autant plus
intense et urgentes à Mayotte cette
proportion de loi contribue en partie à
lever le groupe est des pays votre a
positivement cette mesure merci
chers collègues et la parole est
maintenant à Bernard jaumier pour le
groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame la présidente Madame la
rapporteur mes chers collègues
notre monde vit assez de malheur
actuellement pour qu'on essaye au moins
lui en épargner un c'est de mal nommer
les choses
or cette proposition de loi et je
l'entends depuis la présentation par son
auteur je crois qu'il n'est plus là
installe cette confusion
elle a été déposée au mois de janvier
dernier avec un titre qui porte sur la
formation des internes en médecine
générale et la lutte contre les déserts
médicaux
huit mois après alors qu'elle est
inscrite en sciences publiques
la partie lutte contre les déserts
médicaux a été effacés du titre mais
omniprésente dans les propos de
l'initiateur de la proposition de loi
lui-même et des collègues qui à tour de
rôle se sont exprimés sur cette PPL
alors si ça n'est pas de la confusion
dans le débat il faut m'expliquer ce que
ça signifie
et ça n'est pas parce que le titre a été
exclurgé que cette proposition porte
bien sur la formation des internes de
médecine générale et je voudrais
vraiment insister sur ce point parce que
je pense que c'est un des problèmes
actuels du débat public dans notre pays
c'est de masquer les objectifs et de ne
pas les dire clairement à ceux qui sont
les premiers concernés en l'occurrence
les jeunes médecins qui sont visés par
ce dispositif
nous nous préférons le langage des
intentions qui sont clairement affirmées
et à cet homme c'est un texte qui est
maladroit notre vie publique est
beaucoup trop encombrée de propos qui
sont euphémisés nous le voyons tous les
jours maintenant dans notre pays quand
on parle de concertation ça veut dire en
gros cost toujours et quand on parle de
co-construction ça veut dire on fait
comme j'ai prévu
et c'est ce qui est en train de se
passer sur ce dossier là alors le
président
Bruno Retailleau nous connaissons ses
capacités d'analyse de clarté et de
synthèse je ne veux pas croire une
minute qui les a perdus tout récemment
et donc
et donc il faut clarifier il faut que
clarifier la véritable question qui se
pose à nous c'est est-ce que l'on peut
conjuguer dans un dispositif unique
l'objectif d'une meilleure
professionnalisation des études de
médecine générale avec l'apport de temps
médical supplémentaire au bénéfice d'une
population qui en a besoin donc en clair
doit-on proposer demander aux jeunes
médecins de pas participer à une
meilleure offre de soins dans les 85 90%
de notre territoire qui en a bien besoin
et de deux choses l'une si ce n'est
qu'une question de formation comme le
dit cette intitulé encore une fois alors
la quatrième année n'a rien à faire ici
car ce n'est pas le Parlement qui jamais
ce n'est pas la loi qui décide de la
longueur des cycles des études de
médecine
jamais ce n'est pas le Parlement qui
décide des lieux dans lesquels les
étudiants doivent effectuer leur stage
et oui alors on peut dire que le
gouvernement en inscrivant le dispositif
dans le PLFSS prend un risque d'un
constitutionnalité mais moi je dis qu'en
en faisant une proposition de loi on
abaisse le niveau de la loi dans un
débat d'ordre réglementaire
mais si comme nous le pensons mais c'est
comme nous le pensons
on peut proposer ce dispositif qui porte
ces deux objectifs alors il faut
commencer par tenir un langage de vérité
au premier concerné ce qui sont l'objet
les jeunes médecins et d'abord leur dire
fortement que nous savons qu'ils ne sont
pas responsables de la graves pénurie de
médecins que connaît notre pays nous
sommes un pays qui omi tant des années
70 formé 10000 médecins par an nous
avons abaissé à 3250 par an ce nombre et
actuellement nous en sortons 8500 par an
comment y aurait-il pas une pénurie
profonde alors que notre pays dans le
même temps est passé de 50 millions
d'habitants à plus de 65 et avec un
vieillissement de la population des
problématiques d'autonomie et de
dépendance et les jeunes ne sont en rien
responsable de cet état de fait ce sont
les gouvernements successifs obsédés par
une politique de l'offre il s'agissait
de réduire les dépenses de santé en
réduisant le nombre de médecins formés
et à cette décision des gouvernants ont
participé activement des syndicats
professionnels médicaux
mais aussi avec de nouveaux parcours de
soins avec de nouvelles organisations
territoriales avec des nouveaux enjeux
sociaux qui parfois sont plus prévenants
et qui rentrent inopérants une approche
qui est purement sanitaire et donc
conjuguer une meilleure
professionnalisation avec l'apport de
temps médical dans nos territoires
sous dotés mais donc il s'agit bien de
reconnaître le cas de pédagogique et
l'apport de santé publique
la bonne réponse ne se situe pas dans la
quatrième année d'Internet de médecine
générale mais dans une année de
professionnalisation et les mots ont un
sens qui doit respecter ces jeunes qui
doit reconnaître et rémunérer à sa juste
valeur la contribution demandée qui doit
prendre en compte leurs problématiques
de vie qui doit associer aux universités
les collectivités territoriales qui sont
mieux à même d'assurer des conditions
matérielles de logement de transport de
vie quotidienne qui soit adaptée ce
texte est précipité et nous avons bien
noté d'ailleurs la course qui s'est
engagée entre votre proposition de loi
et le gouvernement pour le PLFSS oui on
a on a bien noté le calendrier qui a été
rappelé par la rapporteur voilà pour
porter à toute vitesse ce dispositif et
je ne doute pas nous avons bien compris
que au moment du PLFSS se renouera une
alliance qu'on a vu lors des textes au
mois de juillet
et oui on en prend le pari si vous
voulez chers collègues c'est ce qui est
en train de se préparer mais là c'est
précipité c'est précipités car il ne
doit pas être inscrit aujourd'hui dans
la loi la quatrième année de médecine du
troisième cycle de médecine générale il
doit être négocié avec les jeunes
médecins avec leurs organisations
syndicales en quoi ils peuvent apporter
du temps médical supplémentaire au
bénéfice de notre population et de la
santé publique ils y sont prêts mais pas
alors que le Parlement aura délibéré on
négocie d'abord on vote la loi ensuite
cette proposition de loi est donc à bien
des égards contre-productives elle ne
pose pas un cadre qui soit adapté et le
législateur comme étré une erreur s'il
venait à prendre la décision de changer
avec sabructo la durée du troisième
cycle de médecine générale nous nous
appelons volontarisme de la négociation
de la responsabilité partagée oui d'une
meilleure formation et d'un temps
médical augmenté oui sans ces conditions
nous voterons contre cette proposition
je vous remercie
merci chers collègues et la parole est
maintenant à Alain Milon pour le groupe
les républicains pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame la Présidente de la
Commission d'affaires sociales madame la
rapporteur cher Corinne en 1947
Jean-François gravier publié Paris et le
désert français
ouvrage qui fit longtemps en référence
et dans lequel l'auteur démontrait le
fort déséquilibre entre Paris et la
province et les conséquences qui en
résultait
75 ans plus tard la rhétorique du désert
retrouve une acuité et une actualité
particulièrement sensible notamment en
matière médicale depuis quelques
dizaines d'années Bernard
depuis quelques dizaines d'années
plusieurs dizaines d'années peut-être
même une quarantaine une quête au moins
40 ans le désert médicaux se répandent
sur l'ensemble du territoire et ne sont
plus un phénomène uniquement rural les
villes et notamment les quartiers
périphériques sont concernés la question
est de savoir si c'est déserts médicaux
sont des phénomènes spécifiques ou s'ils
ne sont pas davantage la conséquence
d'un phénomène global lié à la
disparition des services publics dans
les territoires ruraux et certains
quartiers suburbains peut-on
raisonnablement dans ces conditions
espérées l'installation de médecins et
de leur famille dans des lieux
sous-équipés en service public de
qualité notamment scolaires et culturel
stricto sensibles peut-on
raisonnablement envisager que la vie et
le rythme de travail d'un médecin de
campagne des années
1970-1980 correspondent aux attentes des
nouvelles générations ce constat vaut
également pour la médecine de ville les
évolutions des mentalités la
juridiscide il a
juridiscalisée excusez-moi juridie
sixation la juridicisation de la société
impacte nécessairement les installations
en libéral je savais que je butrais sur
le mot face à cette situation complexe
cette situation multicosale il est
impératif de proposer des solutions
permettant de concilier les attentes des
jeunes médecins avec celles d'une
patientèle inquiète de voir son accès
aux soins limités la PPL donc déposée
par le président Bruno retaillod
s'inscrit dans cette volonté d'apporter
d'une part des réponses précises à nos
concitoyens et aux élus locaux qui sont
souvent en première ligne face aux
doléances de leurs administrer et
d'améliorer d'autres parts le cursus de
formation des étudiants en médecine
générale cette préoccupation n'est pas
nouvelle pour le Sénat car dès 1919 des
2019 nous avions adopté monsieur le
ministre un dispositif presque similaire
mais restez l'être morte en l'absence de
décret d'application qui relevait du
gouvernement aujourd'hui le gouvernement
a ajouté à la hâte un article dans le
PLFSS reprenant quasiment les termes de
cette PPL sans y apporter la moindre
plus-value
la méthode est pour le moins discutable
car elle traduit une forme de mépris à
l'égard du travail parlementaire en se
l'appropriant en catimini au lieu de le
valoriser mais les centres côté ce
problème méthodologique est
concentrons-nous sur les dispositions de
ce texte qui ont fait l'objet de débat
forte intéressant en commission des
affaires sociales madame la reporter
tant le sujet revêt différentes
dimensions sociétales d'aménagement de
territoire et bien évidemment de
formation de nos étudiants je sais que
les internes aujourd'hui contestent le
bien fondé de cette réforme en raison de
la logements d'un an de la durée du
troisième cycle des études de médecine
générale en outre l'obligation de
réaliser cette quatrième année en stage
ambulatoire en autonomie supervisée et
prioritairement dans les zones soudances
identifiées par les ARS les inquiets
parfois aussi il convient de souligner
les apports de ce texte pour la
professionnalisation des internes en
médecine générale grâce à cette année
supplémentaire ils acquériront le statut
docteur junior dont il ne bénéficient
pas aujourd'hui et ils seront mieux
préparés à l'exercice de la médecine en
ville grâce à l'accompagnement d'un
médecin superviseur ce texte constitue
donc une réelle avancée même si certains
points restent en suspens c'est le cas
notamment des conditions de rémunération
de ces étudiants mais également de leurs
conditions d'accueil dans les communes
en matière d'hébergement en matière de
transport ça a déjà été dit ces frais
seront-ils à la seule charge des
collectivités comment les inciter à
aller dans ces zones soudances de même
la question de l'encadrement demeure
essentiel le nombre de maîtres de stage
formé sera-t-il suffisant et répartit
équitablement sur l'ensemble du
territoire le versement des honoraires
pédagogiques des maîtres de stage
devront être réglés dans des délais
raisonnables et non plusieurs mois après
la fin des stages des internes
contrairement à ce qui se passe
actuellement ces retards de paiement
pénalisent et démotivent des stages qui
se sont engagés dans ce processus
d'accompagnement et de formation des
internes enfin il convient de mener une
réflexion sur le lien entre la création
de postes d'interne et le bassin de vie
des lieux d'implantation des universités
en termes de démographie de territoire
de situation sanitaire de la sociologie
ceci afin d'éviter des distorsions entre
la réalité de terrain et le nombre
d'interformés dans les centres
hospitaliers universitaires un exemple
simple dans les alpes-maries
20 postes d'interne en médecine générale
c'est largement insuffisant je conclus
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs mes chers collègues cette PPL
pose les jalons d'une répartition
géographique plus équilibrée tout en
respectant le libre choix d'installation
des futurs médecins principes cardinal
de notre médecine
merci chers collègues
et la parole est maintenant à Anne
Ventalon groupe les républicains pour 4
minutes
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues comment la
France nation à la médecine réputée et
aussi thème de soins généreux et ont
envié on était à l'arrivée à cette
situation de pénurie aujourd'hui 11% de
la population française serait dépourvue
de médecins traitant cette proportion
atteignant parfois le double comme dans
mon département de l'Ardèche sans doute
notre pays a-t-il refusé de considérer
la question du nombre de médecins sur le
long terme c'est là une responsabilité
partagée il n'est que de lire les
échanges entre le gouvernement et les
parlementaires du début des années 90
aux élus qui s'inquiétaient des
conséquences des baisses successives du
numerus clausus en deuxième année de
médecine sur la démographie médicale à
venir les gouvernants répondaient par
des courbes statistiques et des
projections l'unifiantes
il faut donc appréhender le sujet en
sachant que de notre inertie ou de nos
actions dépendra l'accès aux soins des
temps à venir c'est décennies qui seront
marqués par le vieillissement et la
perte d'autonomie de la génération du
baby-boom pour cela nous deux nous
savons que nous devons considérer le
problème sans tabou mais que le salut ne
viendra ni des slogans ni des mirettes
des miracles mais d'une conjugaison de
solutions complémentaires et des forts
collectifs étant les représentants au
Parlement des collectivités locales il
est de notre devoir de nous emparer du
sujet en proposant des solutions
concrètes et viables et je salue en cela
l'initiative de Bruno Retailleau
car à présent ce sont essentiellement
les élus des territoires qui
investissent dans des solutions
pragmatiques elles le font notamment
avec la création de maison de santé
pluridisciplinaire le salariat des
médecins le recrutement des personnels
les déchargeants des tâches
administratives chronophages ou même
comme le fait le département de
l'Ardèche en répondant concrètement à la
question du logement des internes
la mesure proposée par le groupe les
républicaines n'a pas la prétention de
régler à elle seule la pénurie des
médecins généralistes mais dans saisir
un volet important celui de la présence
médicale les internes qui ont
constituent l'un des rouages importants
ne doivent nullement se sentir montré du
doigt et tenu pour futur responsables de
la situation au contraire nous
considérons qu'il constitue une partie
de la solution cette année
supplémentaire de formation de
consolidation ne résoudra pas à elle
seule le problème de la désertification
médicale mais elle constitue l'un des
leviers actionnés aux côtés d'autres
tels que meilleur recours aux infirmiers
en pratique avancées aux assistants
médicaux à la restructuration de l'offre
de soins qui conjointement permettront
de restaurer le droit à la santé pour
chacun
cette quatrième année d'internat et
Madame la rapporteur l'a rappelé
permettra d'aligner la formation des
futurs généralistes avec le cursus des
autres spécialisations en réalisant des
stages en autonomie progressive et en
bénéficiant de la superficie de la
supervision pardon de médecins
expérimentés il bénéfiront également
d'une rémunération supérieure à celle
reçue pendant leurs années d'internat de
plus au cours de cette année passée dans
les localités sous dotées c'est futurs
médecins prendront toute la mesure du
délaissement pour ne pas dire de la
détresse médicale de certaines
territoires notamment ruraux ce qui
allobe de leur carrière
sensibilisera autant ses praticiens qui
ont fait de la santé une vocation quelle
mobilisera la conscience civique de ces
jeunes citoyens je vous remercie
merci
merci chers collègues la discussion
générale est donc close et nous allons
passer à la discussion du texte de la
commission et de son article unique
alors j'ai plusieurs demandes de prise
de parole sur l'article unique donc on
va commencer avec notre collègue Fabien
Genet
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre de la présidente Madame la
rapporteur je voudrais saluer cette
initiative de consolidation et de
professionnalisation de la formation des
internes en médecine générale contenu
dans cet article 1 car si cette
initiative n'affiche plus pour objectif
la lutte contre les déserts médicaux
elle représente tout de même un espoir
pour nombre de territoires qui en sont
privés j'ai entendu que certains
s'interrogeraient sur un dispositif trop
précipité ou qu'on accuserait de mettre
la charrue avant les boeufs alors vous
permettrait à les lucha relay que je
suis de vous dire qu'on a plutôt le
sentiment dans nos campagnes qu'on a
beaucoup trop tardé en 2014 comme maire
de Digoin j'ai été confronté au départ
de la moitié des médecins généralistes
en quelques mois et à l'angoisse de la
population privée de soignants confronté
à l'irresponsabilité totale de notre
système de santé aucune institution ne
faisant quoi que ce soit et l'Agence
Régionale de Santé finissant par
renvoyer les patients vers le maire que
j'étais depuis heureusement la situation
c'est localement améliorée avec la
création par exemple d'un centre
départemental de santé par le président
Akari qui salariés des médecins mais
aussi avec la mise en place d'une maison
de santé pluridisciplinaire soutenue par
l'intercommunalité portée par une équipe
de médecins extrêmement dévouée dont
d'ailleurs une majorité de jeunes
médecins je pourrais bien sûr vous
parler comme ma collègue Marie Mercier
d'autres communes comme Cuisery ou
Genouilly qui cherche encore leur
médecin tout cela pour dire monsieur le
ministre que votre tâche n'est pas
facile mais elle est vital nos
concitoyens des territoires ruraux
s'adaptent de Gréoux de force aux
délégations de tâches au cabines de
télémédecine et demain au médecin
stagiaires car ils n'ont pas d'autre
choix mais il ne seraient accepté qu'on
finisse par entériner le principe d'une
médecine d'une médecine à deux vitesses
monsieur le ministre l'urgence de la
situation commande donc des mesures
complémentaires et structurelles à cette
initiative d'aujourd'hui une vraie
mobilisation générale pour ne pas
oublier le grand sacrifié de cette
situation le patient
merci merci chers collègues donc
toujours des interventions de deux
minutes maintenant notre collègue Katia
pourceau poli
merci monsieur le Président
après l'intervention de ma collègue
Laurence Cohen je souhaitais intervenir
à mon tour sur cet article unique et ses
limites
il y a quelques années les études de
médecine durait 7 ans pensez-vous que
les médecins étaient moins compétents
pour ma part je ne le pense pas je m'en
sors pas trop mal j'avais un médecin qui
avait fait 7 ans d'étude et donc
apparemment ça va finalement je m'en
sors mal parce que maintenant au coeur
du bassin mignon on a plus de médecin
donc on s'en sort bien plus mal elles
sont aujourd'hui ces études de médecine
de 9 ans et avec cette proposition de
loi elle serait de mettre 10 ans
pensez-vous vraiment que faire une année
de plus ça va régler la question des
déserts médicaux en plus il faudra des
médecins seniors pour encadrer ses
internes vous n'êtes pas sans avoir
qu'il en manque partout en urbain comme
en ruralité qui donc encadre assez jeune
à terme volontaires car on parle bien
sûr de volontariat et évidemment à
moindre coût je rappelle quand même
qu'on va les payer 2000 à 2500 euros par
mois pour 10 ans d'études
plus que jamais je pense qu'il nous faut
réfléchir à l'installation nous ne
pouvons pas continuer à laisser
s'installer dans les zones de soins à
forexcédent des médecins autrement nous
ne réglerons pas le problème bien au
contraire il va s'aggraver nous sommes
favorables plus qu'à une dixième année à
la réduction du premier cycle et du
second cycle après discussion et
Concertation il nous faut une véritable
loi pour rediscuter de la refonte des
études de médecine dans son ensemble
avec l'ensemble des partenaires
concernés car il n'y a plus de numérus
clausus vous l'avez dit Monsieur le
Ministre j'ai bien entendu vous disiez
que les effets ne se verraient que dans
10 ans
malheureusement
les effets seront là que dans 10 ans si
on desserre l'étau pour former plus de
médecins et si on donne les moyens
immédiats au nombre de places dans les
facultés je vous remercie chers
collègues la parole est maintenant à
notre collègue Pierre Ouzoulias
merci monsieur le Président summisme mes
chers collègues on l'a dit l'hôpital
public il peut pas fonctionner
aujourd'hui sans les internes c'est une
une réalité j'aimerais rappeler de
chiffres la formation d'un médecin
généraliste coûte à l'université environ
104.000 euros par personne et pas et par
an et le travail qu'il fournisse lui il
estimé à 121.000 euros je rappelle que
les internes de médecine gagnent en
moyenne 6 euros de l'heure et que 70%
des internes déplace le dépasse pardon
le plafond hebdomadaire légal de 48
heures en travaillant environ 58 heures
par semaine coût de la formation 104000
euros
chiffrage du travail qu'ils apportent
121.000 euros les étudiants en médecine
sont les seules étudiants en France qui
rapportent de l'argent à l'état les
étudiants
il faut le répéter parce qu'ils le
vivent comme une profonde
injustice ils ne comprennent pas qu'on
reconnaisse ce qu'ils apportent
aujourd'hui à la médecine et ce qu'ils
ont fait pendant la période du covid
souvenez-vous vous les avez appuyé
applaudi pour 6 euros de l'heure c'est
ça la réalité aujourd'hui le travail
lors de son audition par la commission
de la culture du Sénat le président de
France université Monsieur Manuel du nom
de Lara ancien président de l'université
de Bordeaux et praticien hospitalier
déclarait je le cite les CHU vont dans
le mur les hospitalots universitaires
sont noyés sous des tâches cliniques
entre 50 et 60 professeurs de médecine
ont démissionné depuis 2018 est-ce que
c'est vraiment la réforme qu'on besoin
aujourd'hui les études de santé merci
monsieur le président
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant à notre collègue Bruno
rejoint
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame la Présidente de la
Commission madame leur rapporteur en
commission aménagement du territoire et
développement durable nous avons
beaucoup travaillé sur ce sujet de
l'accès aux soins dans les territoires
qui malheureusement sont très nombreux
en France maintenant je dois dire qu'il
est intéressant que la Commission
aménagement du territoire ce soit aussi
emparé de ce sujet là parce que c'est
une manière c'est une vision peut-être
un peu différente de la commission des
affaires sociales au moins au moins dans
le fait d'aborder ce sujet
alors moi je suis très heureux je me dis
enfin une PPL celle du président rotaïo
aujourd'hui qui envoie un message fort
vers ces populations délaissées dans les
territoires et surtout vers les élus
locaux les élus locaux chaque fois que
nous lui déplaçons dans une réunion
irrémédiablement les maires nous parlent
de la du problématique de la présence
médicale dans leur commune dans leur
communauté de communes donc c'est un
message c'est le premier message fort
envoyé par notre assemblée en direction
de ces élus locaux que nous qui sont nos
partenaires numéro 1 mais vu la
situation désastreuse dans laquelle
effectivement et la santé en France il
ne faudra pas s'en arrêter là le Sénat
la représentation des territoires et le
lieu même où finalement on doit discuter
et je propose bien que finalement cette
ce vote qui va avoir lieu tout à l'heure
soit l'étape 1 de quelque chose car il
faudra revenir et tous presque vous
l'avez dit d'une manière différente mais
il faudra revenir avec ce sujet là car
on ne va pas le régler par cette seule
disposition
un ensemble mesure un ensemble de
mesures que suite au travail fait dans
la commission j'ai rédigé au sein d'une
PPL et déposer
seul cet ensemble de mesures pris à peu
près simultanément ou du moins dans des
temps assez raccourcis va pouvoir
permettre que les Français les 6
millions de Français et les autres
vont pouvoir voir leur situation
s'améliorer ainsi donc je pense que
aujourd'hui
de départ d'une discussion beaucoup plus
longue sur l'accès aux soins des
Français dans leur territoire merci
merci
la parole il y a beaucoup de collègues
inscrits dans la discussion générale
donc je fais respecter les temps de
parole la parole à notre collègue
Jean-Luc Fichet
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues et
j'aimerais tellement que ça marche
parce que ce n'est pas nouveau ça fait
10 ans qu'on débat de cette question
dans cette hémicycle et ça fait 10 ans
qu'on liste un certain nombre de
dispositions pour essayer de répondre à
la question des déserts médicaux et avec
mon collègue Hervé Moret en 2011-2012 on
a produit déjà un premier rapport qui
identifie le problème et qui fait des
propositions qui changent sans doute des
propositions qui pour la période et sont
un peu coercitives un peu dur dans tous
les cas elles existaient et elles n'ont
pas réellement changé en termes de
nécessité alors qu'est-ce qui se passe
dans cette nouvelle proposition alors
moi je vais pas évoquer la quatrième
année parce que je pense effectivement
que ce n'est pas notre sujet mais on
utilise la quatrième année
sujet de formation pour essayer quand
même de manière masquée de répondre à la
question des déserts médicaux et
qu'est-ce qu'on dit on dit voilà
si vous avez un maître de stage
si le maire veut bien mettre un logement
à votre disposition si il veut bien vous
mettre une voiture à disposition et
pourquoi pas s'il veut bien créer un
cabinet médical si toutes ces
conditions-là sont réunies vous
stagiaire du 4e année vous pouvez
prioritairement faire votre stage dans
des lieux soudains où il n'y a pas de
médecin ça veut dire qu'ils ont dit il y
a un potentiel de 3700 médecins moi je
ne crois pas à ça je n'y crois pas du
tout parce qu'effectivement on l'a assez
bien expliqué ici les internes ont une
autre approche une autre vision moi je
suis d'accord avec mon collègueulasse
sur le fait que il faut reconsidérer la
manière dont on voit les internes à
l'hôpital parce que c'est à la limite de
la maltraitance mais c'est de
l'esclavage mais c'est autre chose que
d'autres questions des déserts médicaux
la question des désirs médicaux c'est
comment aujourd'hui l'État répartit
l'ensemble des médecins de manière
retarde sur le territoire et comment
chaque administré un médecin apporté de
30 minutes à peu près et je crois que
c'est cette question là qu'il faut
résoudre mais et la proposition de cet
après-midi ne va absolument pas dans ce
sens là je vous remercie merci chers
collègues et la parole est maintenant à
Stéphane Sautarel
merci monsieur le Président je voulais à
mon tour me joindre à la voix d'un
certain nombre de collègues pour bien
évidemment remettre ce texte et cette
proposition dans son dans son contexte
donc d'abord pour dire merci à notre
groupe à Bruno Retailleau j'ai moi-même
consigné cette cette PPL parce qu'elle
me semble indispensable et et comme
chacun l'a dit non suffisante bien
évidemment ce n'est qu'une partie de la
réponse mais je dis aussi enfin parce
que il y a un signe il y a une
exaspération dans nos territoires qui
est elle que si on n'est pas capable de
répondre à l'offre de soins de plus de 6
millions de Français et en particulier
dans nos territoires ruraux d'autres
questions vont se poser en termes
d'accès aux services publics d'accès aux
services les trois services prioritaires
c'est la sécurité la santé et
l'éducation si notre pays si dans cet
assemblée nous ne sommes pas en capacité
de répondre et désormais dans l'urgence
parce que leur est grave leur le temps
presse à ce besoin là nous ne pas à la
hauteur de la confiance que nos
administrés que nos concitoyens que nos
électeurs que les contribuables
plaçons-nous bien évidemment qu'il y a
des sujets plus globaux au niveau de la
santé au niveau de la situation des
internes et que c'est pas par les
internes que l'on peut résoudre
l'ensemble de la question et qu'il
convient d'examiner la place des
internes et la situation des internes
dans notre système de santé c'est bien
évident mais je pense que ce premier
signe qui est envoyé aujourd'hui à des
territoires qui sont en désespérance il
faut entendre ça sur l'offre de santé
que nous offrons à à nos concitoyens
comme plusieurs collègues l'ont rappelé
me semble être une absolue priorité et
donc je veux juste insister sur sur
cette nécessité là qui bien sûr n'a pas
été anticipé mais aujourd'hui on peut
débattre on peut continuer à réfléchir
mais il faut comprendre il faut qu'on
avance il faut qu'on agisse et donc
merci pour ce débat qui est ouvert
aujourd'hui et qui j'espère ce sera un
premier pas dans cette direction merci
chers collègues la parole est maintenant
à Jean-Pierre Sueur
sur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
notre collègue Patrice Joly a présenté
deux amants
donc il vient de parler Jean-Luc Fichet
ces deux amendements eux portent sur les
effets les conséquences le rapport entre
la formation et la présence médicale et
notamment la désertification médicale
ces deux amendements ont été retirés de
l'ordre du jour ils ne seront pas
présentés en vertu d'une interprétation
monsieur le Président par rapport à
laquelle je tiens à dire mon profond
désaccord de l'article 45 de la
Constitution je vous rappelle que cet
article dit que tout amendement en
première lecture et recevable dès lors
qu'il présente un rapport même indirect
avec le texte si quelqu'un ici peut
m'expliquer que ces deux amendements
n'ont aucun rapport indirect avec le
texte je les remercie de le faire faute
de quoi nous sommes dans l'arbitraire
donc je protesterai une nouvelle fois et
chaque fois que ça se présentera sur
cette interprétation qui est faite ici
de l'article 45 de la Constitution
merci Monsieur le Kester et maintenant
le la parole est à notre collègue
Elisabeth Doisneau de l'Union centriste
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales madame
la rapporteur chers collègues il faut
toujours saluer les initiatives qui font
parler de sujets qui sont très
importants pour notre société et je vous
remercie le président retaillod d'avoir
en tout cas eu cette initiative je
remercie aussi monsieur le ministre
d'avoir finalement corroboré à travers
un article de dans le PLFSS à cette
proposition même si le titre a changé en
réalité nous avons plus parlé
aujourd'hui des problèmes de démographie
médicale que de la professionnalisation
des professionnels de santé et je le
regrette tout simplement je voudrais
dire pourquoi moi j'ai des doutes parce
que il y a des écueils en fait dans
cette proposition de loi et le premier
écueil c'est en fait qu'il y a une non
adhésion des jeunes étudiants en
médecine et pour moi il est important
que l'on décide ici de loi qui sont en
parfaites accords au moins avec la
majorité de ceux qui seront concernés
c'est très important ils étaient 10
[Musique]
PPL donc je vois que mon temps est
terminé en tout cas moi je m'abstiendrai
sur cette proposition merci
merci chers collègues et la parole est à
Emmanuel Capu du groupe Les Indépendants
merci monsieur le Président pour ma part
je soutiens sans aucune réserve la
proposition de loi qui est présentée
aujourd'hui elle va exactement dans le
même sens que celle que j'avais cosigné
de mon collègue Daniel Chassin qui était
inscrite à l'ordre du jour de jeudi
prochain dans la niche des indépendants
et que Daniel chassaint donc retiré
puisqu'elle était exactement sur le même
sujet et elle a proposé exactement le
même type de solution que celle
d'aujourd'hui je pense qu'il faut
dépasser les groupes politiques et se
réunir sur ce sujet pourquoi parce que
dans nos territoires et cela concerne
tous les territoires tous les
territoires français dans notre
circonstance dans nos circonscriptions
en Maine-et-Loire il n'y a pas une
commune qui n'est pas confrontée à cette
difficulté je ne parle pas des médecins
spécialistes pour lesquels les
rendez-vous c'est à 6 mois je parle des
généralistes pour lesquels quand il n'y
a pas de médecin il n'y a pas de médecin
et les rendez-vous sont il y a pas de
rendez-vous en fait il pas de
rendez-vous aujourd'hui on répond à la
population y compris Angers mais pas que
dans les zones rurales on répond si vous
n'êtes pas aujourd'hui notre patient
nous ne vous prenons pas pointe à la
ligne et c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous avons autant de personnes qui ne
sont pas suivies donc il y a urgence il
y a pénurie et cette pénurie qui fait
face ce sont les mères qui se
débrouillent dans certaines communes
certains ingénieux ont salariés leur
médecin ils lui font d'ailleurs souvent
une opération financière relativement
intéressante dans d'autres il
construisent des maisons de santé à leur
frais dans d'autres encore il faut venir
des médecins roumains ou d'autres pays
partout c'est la débrouille donc nous
devons aider les maires ruraux à trouver
des solutions celles qui est proposée
aujourd'hui est une bonne solution elle
passe également parce qu'ils avaient
Doisneau a raison par une solution
extrêmement simple et que je pense qui
est soulevé sur chaque banc ça passe par
l'adhésion évidemment des étudiants
internes en médecine et donc par une
juste rémunération de l'effort et qu'ils
font au service notamment de la ruralité
merci chers collègues la parole à notre
collègue Sonia de la pauvreté
merci monsieur le Président chers
collègues un médecin généraliste un
médecin de famille c'est un choix
des jeunes qui s'engagent en cette voie
sont les pivots les piliers de la
médecine de demain et ils ont vraiment à
cœur profondément le service public et
l'écoute des autres pourquoi il
s'installe pas voilà pourquoi il ne
s'installe pas une fois qu'ils ont fait
leurs études pourquoi ils remplacent
longtemps pourquoi il se rémunéré la
consultation moins de la moyenne
européenne pourquoi il choisissent des
exercices particuliers en cours de
carrière parce que ils sont ils ont de
tels contraintes d'exercices qu'il
choisissent de faire autre chose que que
cet exercice là pourquoi elle se salarie
parce que la sécurité sociale salarié
des médecins parce qu'on a des médecins
coordinateurs parce qu'on trouve tout un
tas de postes pour lesquels on emploie
les médecins autre chose qu'au soin de
premier recours c'est fameux médecin
généraliste qui sont un tiers un tiers
des médecins de promotion reçus à
l'internat et parmi eux au final on en
retrouvera qu'un cinquième à être en
soins de premier recours auprès des
habitants dans les territoires alors moi
je ne voterai pas cette proposition là
parce qu'on n'a pas à régler les
questions on a pas réglé la question de
la rémunération on n'a pas réglé la
question de la qualité de l'exercice on
n'a pas réglé la question de considérer
que finalement c'est l'heure rôle à eux
qui est le plus important et le pilier
de notre métier je vous remercie
merci la parole maintenant à Bruno Belin
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre
on va pas revenir comme la fée Bernard
jaumier sur ce qui s'est passé il y a 30
ou 40 ans c'était au tournant des années
90 on a baissé les numérus clossus chers
collègues uniquement à l'époque
rappelez-vous parce qu'il fallait faire
des économies de sécurité sociale et on
a sacrifié des vagues d'étudiants qui
nous serait bien utile aujourd'hui ah
même sur le ministre
notre journée est historique je
comprenne date tous les deux et vous
devant notre assemblée bien évidemment
parce que on nous a raconté qu'à la fin
du numérique clausus tout allait aller
bien et on invente ce que aucun de nous
aurait été capable d'expliquer il y a
six mois
le numerus apertus alors en attendant le
numerus Proximus on a le droit au
numerus à Perthus alors l'humérus
apertuse pardonnez-moi de prendre une
minute 10 pour vous l'expliquer c'est ce
sont pardon les universités qui fixe
elle-même le nombre d'étudiants quels
sont en volonté ou en capacité de former
et donc des riches font des riches et
des pauvres font des pauvres et donc
vous trouverez toujours plus d'étudiants
formés à Paris Ouest que vous pouvez
trop en trouver à Clermont-Ferrand ou
dans d'autres universités de province et
donc moi je prends date monsieur le
ministre cher docteur numéro sapertus on
a bien compris que c'est la règle
maintenant il va falloir nous en faire
vite l'évaluation c'est à dire qu'est-ce
que ça a changé concrètement dans toutes
les universités françaises catégories de
médecins par catégorie de profession de
santé combien de places sont données
qu'est-ce que ça va donner êtes-vous
prêt à le révéler et de vous prêt à
l'expliquer quelle est la transparence
sur le numerus à Perthus merci monsieur
le président
merci chers collègues la parole
maintenant à Patrick Joly merci monsieur
le Président Monsieur ministre et chers
collègues pour revenir sur ce qui a été
dit précédemment je suis très surpris
effectivement que cette PPL au départ
qui avait vocation explicitement traitée
des arts médicaux se trouve avec un
intitulé qui estompé d'une partie du
sujet qui est essentiel
je suis surpris parce que l'enjeu
aujourd'hui de l'accès à la santé dans
les territoires ruraux notamment mais
pas seulement bien sûr et véritablement
majeur c'est l'égalité aujourd'hui qui
est bafoué avec des conséquences sur la
qualité de vie de nos concitoyens avec
pire des conséquences sur l'espérance de
vie de nos concitoyens des écarts pour
aller jusqu'à 5 ans comme dans mon
département la Nièvre
il y a donc urgence sur Jean sanitaire
bien sûr urgence politique aussi tant
l'attente de nos concitoyens est grande
pour une prise en main par les
politiques de l'organisation de la
présence sanitaire sur nos territoires
pour cela il faut redéfinir les zones
dites sûreté et celles dites sous dotées
sortir de la théorie de la prise en
charge de optimale du nombre de patients
du nombre de patients par médecin au
regard de la pénurie que nous vivons
aujourd'hui les zones soudances sont des
zones dont le nombre de médecins est
inférieur à la moyenne nationale et les
zones surdantes sont des zones dans
lesquelles le nombre moyen de médecins
est supérieur à la moyenne nationale et
c'est aussi simple que cela
urgence de cette reprise en main je le
disais c'est le sens de la PPL qui a
bien voulu évoquer notre collègue
Jean-Pierre Sueur tout à l'heure une PPL
que j'avais déposée en août dernier avec
comme principal disposition une
situation en matière de conventionnement
la réduction de la possibilité de faire
des intérims pour éviter sortir de ce
scandale garantir des aides à
l'installation pour les employeurs qui
embauchent des des
médecins comme pour les libéraux il y a
urgence
urgence monsieur le ministre les
Français sont en souffrance les Français
souffrent monsieur le ministre au
secours au nom des territoires les
habitants des territoires ruraux
agissaient concrètement agissez vite
[Applaudissements]
allez-y chers collègues madame
merci monsieur le Président je suis
assez gêné vraiment gêné de prendre la
parole à ce stade mais je tiens à
apprendre quand même parce que je suis
gêné pourquoi parce qu'il s'agit de
parler de la formation des internes en
médecine générale et je crois que parler
de la formation des internes en médecine
générale ça me pose un problème parce
que préalablement et ça a été dit il
s'agissait de parler des airs médicaux
en même temps c'était le titre initial
en tout cas c'était une partie de
l'intitulé
sur les territoires d'outre-mer mais
c'est aussi partout en France il y a de
vrais problèmes on parle pas à ce stade
et j'ai entendu les différentes prises
de la parole la qualité la qualité des
soins l'aménagement du territoire c'est
vrai ça a été évoqué mais je crois qu'il
y a de vrais problèmes et que cette PPL
ne peut pas résoudre est également les
difficultés qu'on rencontre nos
territoires je crois également que la
qualité de vie des internes parce qu'on
parle des internes quand on regarde la
charge de travail qu'il faut moi j'ai
trouvé un milieu hospitalier ce sont des
personnes qui travaillent qui supplient
qui prennent des responsabilités il y a
de vrais sujets et là je vois qu'ils
seront exploités ils ne seront pas
correctement payés on attend beaucoup
d'eux pour nos territoires ça peut
apporter une réponse certes mais est-ce
qu'on parle de ceux qui pendant le
confinement pendant toute la période
sanitaire ce sont suicidés ils ont été à
peu près 11 il faut parler de ça aussi
de la qualité de vie de ces personnes
sur lesquelles nous comptons alors
aujourd'hui je crois que nous nous
trompons quelque part parce que
dissocier les problématiques de
déménagement du territoire de la qualité
de vie de ces personnes là la qualité de
vie de la santé dans notre population et
bien je crois que c'est une grave erreur
merci
merci bien chers collègues nous en avons
terminé avec les interventions générales
sur sur l'article unique et donc nous
allons passer à l'examen des amendements
donc le premier amendement l'amendement
neuf rectifié est présenté par Monsieur
Chaumier
merci monsieur le Président donc
logiquement des coulant des
interventions que nous avons fait dans
cette première partie d'examen du texte
cet amendement il vise
à prendre acte du fait qu'une année de
professionnalisation doit être mise en
place et à renvoyer à la négociation
avec les organisations
concernées des conditions et on les a
beaucoup entendues les conditions j'ai
entendu beaucoup de collègues dire que
la question des rémunérations n'était
pas réglée que la question des des lieux
d'affectation n'étaient pas réglées que
la question des moyens matériels
n'étaient pas réglés et bien tout ça
tout le dispositif doit être négocié le
problème c'est qu'en créant encore une
fois brutalement la quatrième année
d'internat de médecine générale vous
avez l'organisme des internes et de leur
organisation syndicale qui sont en grève
qui dénoncent à la fois l'article 23 du
PLFSS qui est effectivement exactement
le même
cette proposition de loi parce qu'elle
s'assied elle fait fit de la phase de
négociation ce n'est pas l'heure pour
nous de figer le dispositif vous faites
une erreur moi je vous appelle à adopter
cette amendement qui permettra de poser
un principe de renvoyer à l'organisation
entre les parties prenantes et il sera
temps un peu plus tard et pas trop tard
j'en suis bien d'accord mais un peu plus
tard en fonction du résultat de ces
négociations d'adopter un dispositif
définitif bien merci avis de la
commission sur cet amendement
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues tout
d'abord en préambule je voudrais dire
que la proposition loi n'est pas n'est
pas amputée du sujet sur la démographie
médicale bien sûr elle est amputée de
termes désert médicaux qui ne
correspondent pas à la réalité de nos
territoires il y a des problèmes de
démographie médicale partout en France
en 85 % du territoire national et un ami
long rappelait le titre d'un livre que
je ne connaissais pas Paris et ses
désert mais la réalité là est-ce que
d'abord c'est faire insultes à tous les
élus locaux qui cherchent à donner de
l'attractivité à leur territoire et
reconnaissez-le dans tous les
départements il y a des il y a des
territoires attractifs la France n'est
pas un désert donc je voulais simplement
le terme de désert médical d'abord il le
terme de désert médical d'abord il est
je veux dire il est nocif à
l'installation des médecins il donne une
mauvaise image de ce que sont les
territoires soudains ensuite attendez
vous vous prendrez la parole après mes
chers collègues mais ensuite je voulais
juste te dire à Bernard J
nous respectons les alternants médecine
nous les respectons si nous les
respectons la preuve en est c'est que
avec cette proposition de loi si elle
est adoptée en fin de troisième année en
début de 4e année ils seront docteur
junior et nous défendons l'idée c'était
dans l'exposé des motifs de la
proposition de loi d'une rémunération à
l'acte et tout à l'heure et on l'a
examinait en commission tout à l'heure
il sera présenté par le docteur René
Paul Savary un amendement un amendement
justement où nous demandons une
dérogation à la rémunération des
docteurs junior en médecine générale
parce que l'effort qu'on leur demande
nécessite reconnaissance et impose
reconnaissance et je vous joins
parfaitement il est pas tolérable que
des médecins en quatrième future médecin
et des internes en 4e année de médecine
générale avec le savoir qu'ils ont
méritent reconnaissance sur cet
amendement ça se seconde ça va être
court mais en instaurant une année de
stage supplémentaire pour les étudiants
en médecine générale son inclure dans
l'internat cet amendement ne permet pas
de compléter le troisième cycle de
méthyltéral en lui rendant applicable
commencer permise par les réformes de
2017 donc l'ajout d'une phase de
consolidation troisième cycle de
médecine générale parce qu'elle
précipite la soutenance de thèse et
donne accès à des stages en autonomie
supervisé est essentiel à cette réforme
et à la reconnaissance par le titre de
docteur junior donc moi je souhaite
comme vous mon cher collègue que ce soit
défini les modalités de rémunération
adaptée à cette 4e année à ces
contraintes l'inclure dans la troisième
année de cycles de méthyl général
n'empêchera pas le gouvernement et je
compte sur vous monsieur mise de le
faire c'est un avis défavorable de la
commission
avis défavorable la vie du gouvernement
maintenant
ce président madame la rapporteur madame
la présidente madame monsieur sénateurs
Chaumier l'ajout d'une quatrième année
au diplôme au DES de médecine générale
ajustement pour objectif de doter cette
spécialité d'une phase de consolidation
de professionnelisation cette phase
permet un interne d'acquérir de
l'autonomie dans le cadre protecteur de
la supervision à l'instar d'ailleurs des
autres spécialités médicales
par ailleurs je ne suis pas favorable à
la réalisation de cette année de façon
obligatoire dans une zone soudance je ne
crois pas à la concertation non par
dogme mais parce que la concertation ne
fonctionne pas elle est même
contre-productive
je souhaite enfin que les modalités de
rémunération puissent être concertées
dans le cadre de la mission que nous
avons confié avec la ministre
de l'Enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche
je vous remercie de vous interroger sur
la rémunération des internes en médecine
générale tout en précisant que c'est le
même problème avec les internes des
autres spécialités pour toutes ces
raisons je suis et le Gouvernement est
défavorable à votre amendement
bien merci Monsieur le Ministre donc un
double avis défavorable monsieur
ozoulias
merci monsieur le Président merci
monsieur le ministre sur cet amendement
nous avons un doute un doute fort qui
tient
aux capacités du législatif nous sommes
tous très attachés à l'autonomie des
universités j'ai cru même comprendre que
Madame Pécresse a fait une partie de sa
campagne électorale sur ce point
l'autonomie d'université or comme le
disait très justement monsieur jemier
dans son intervention générale pour la
première fois le législateur va
intervenir dans un cursus universitaire
est-ce que vous vous rendez compte de ce
que vous êtes en train de faire et du
changement radical que vous êtes en
train d'impulser avec cette loi dans la
relation que le législatif a avec
l'université comprenez bien que si vous
touchez comme vous le faites aux études
vous touchez aussi au Master c'est à
dire que vous remettez en question tout
le processus de Bologne alors moi je
suis favorable à cette discussion mais
moi j'avais compris que c'était pas
tellement votre position logique vous en
changer ça serait bien de nous
l'expliquer merci monsieur le président
monsieur Jomier
je remercie la rapporteur pour la
précision de sa réponse et de ce
dialogue mais madame la rapporteur que
vous ayez supprimé le terme des airs
médicaux personne n'en échafouint par
contre vous avez effacé vous auriez pu
parler de dispositif visant
à développer à améliorer l'offre l'offre
de soins dans nos territoires parce
qu'on le voit bien encore une fois nous
ne parlons que de ça que de ça dans
cette hémicycle mais on les fasse en
même temps et donc c'est la confusion et
ne cherchez pas ailleurs la raison de la
grève des internes ne cherchez pas
ailleurs la raison de leur manifestation
et de leur opposition à votre
proposition de loi et à l'article 23 tel
qu'il est rédigé
alors quoi on est là pour décider du
mode de rémunération et bien moi je ne
préorme pas la question de savoir si
lors de cette année ils devront recevoir
une part fixe salariale une part à
l'acte un mélange des deux une unicité
de l'un ou de l'autre c'est la
négociation qui dit ça les corps
intermédiaires on les a méprisés pendant
tout un quinquennat nous avons tenu le
discours de l'air valorisé et au moment
de mettre en place un nouveau dispositif
on ne les consulte pas on vote avant la
négociation et bien oui on met la
charrue avant les boeufs il faut d'abord
négocier et après adopter le dispositif
et c'est pour ça que nous maintenons cet
amendement
est-ce que vous avez dit dans votre
explication il y a quelques minutes que
vous n'étiez pas fort pas favorable la
concertation je pense que c'est à la
coercition d'accord on est un peu on est
rassuré merci monsieur le ministre
madame Cohen
oui merci le monsieur le Président
effectivement sinon ça n'avait pas de
sens monsieur le ministre sans vouloir
vous faire de procédés tension parce
qu'elle aura à ce moment-là à quoi
servait le CNR moi je trouve qu'il a pas
beaucoup d'utilité mais enfin bon voilà
c'est quand même soi-disant un organisme
de concertation alors nous au niveau du
groupe communiste
républicain citoyen écologiste on a je
crois bien exprimé notre désaccord avec
cette proposition de loi en tout cas de
manière claire et on ne doit pas rentrer
dans le jeu des amendements parce que on
pense que de toute façon c'est mauvais
c'est pas comme ça qu'on redresse les
choses d'abord par rapport à la façon
dont on traite les internes et y compris
par rapport à ce que l'on vit dans nos
territoires quel qu'il soit ruraux ou
urbain ça n'est pas comme ça qu'il faut
faire il faut desserrer les taux
effectivement du numerus à Perthus et
puis mes chers collègues j'aimerais
quand même attirer votre attention sur
une chose je n'arrive pas à comprendre
que la majorité des jeunes médecins sont
plutôt faut attiré par un exercice en
équipe un exercice salarié et que au
travers d'une PPL ou d'amendement on les
encourage à travailler en libéral là il
y a quand même un hiatus c'est-à-dire
que vraiment on ne veut rien entendre de
ce qu'est la situation réelle de ces
internes et on veut les forcer alors que
on laisse par exemple d'autres
propositions je pense notamment aux
gardes etc pour l'ensemble des médecins
qu'ils soient pas seulement au public
mais aussi en privé on les laisse faire
ce qu'ils veulent là il y a vraiment
deux points de mesure
madame de la pauvreté
merci pour dire que moi je m'abstiendrai
conformément à mon intervention initiale
sur tous ces amendements
quand on arrive en fin de cursus on a 27
26 ans voilà plutôt 27 on a des enfants
en bas âge
et il y a énormément de femmes
évidemment et le conjoint ou la
conjointe sont déjà engagés dans la vie
professionnelle
c'est quand même compliqué de leur dire
après cet engagement volontaire
d'exercer en médecine générale qui est
quand même par les temps qui courent
après engagement enfin une vraie volonté
un vrai sens aiguë du service public et
du service rendu à la population c'est
quand même compliqué de leur dire que à
la fin tout à la fin quand la vie
personnelle est lancée quand ça devient
compliqué et ben non il va falloir aller
dans un désert médical ou l'équivalent
d'un désert médical en tout cas plus
loin de là où on habite pour pour
boucher les trous des carences des
politiques publiques en matière d'accès
aux soins ben moi je trouve que ce
message là il est pas audible et en tout
cas
il est pas acceptable et c'est pas un
message qu'on doit transmettre à des
jeunes qui demain sur lesquels vont
reposer demain
la responsabilité de la prise en charge
dans tous les territoires je vous
remercie
monsieur Savary
oui merci monsieur le Président moi je
voudrais cadrer un petit peu les choses
j'ai participé à un certain nombre
d'ositions la quatrième année tombe pas
du ciel quand même ça fait des années
des années qu'on parle d'une quatrième
année à l'identique des 43 autres
spécialités pour mettre le cursus de
troisième cycle à égalité de façon à ce
que le médecin généraliste soit reconnu
comme la médecine générale soit reconnue
comme une spécialité c'est revendiquer
depuis très longtemps simplement c'était
mis un peu sous le tapis peut-être par
manque de courage au fil des années pour
annoncer la couleur là au moins il y a
une clarté et d'ailleurs quand il s'agit
de formation les internes ça vient que
si c'est pour une formation justement à
l'installation c'est d'autant plus
intéressant puis je voudrais désamorcer
un petit peu du côté de ces territoires
ils vont aller sur des territoires qui
sont plus ou moins attractifs
effectivement mais qui peuvent être très
attractifs mais où il y a un agrément
d'un médecin stagiaire universitaire
quoi qui va les prendre en main alors si
un territoire rural n'a pas de maître de
stage universitaire il aura pas
d'interne attention donc la formation
correspond à un agrément à un suivi avec
un maître de stage qui peut être sur
n'importe quel territoire
c'est la raison pour laquelle faut faire
être tout à fait attentif à cela moi je
crois pas qu'on va aller maltraiter
quand même
sûrement pas autant qu'ils le sont
peut-être déjà à l'hôpital ils vont
bénéficier d'une vie nouvelle découvre
des malades dans des territoires
extraordinaires parfois et je suis sûr
que ça les convaincra d'aller
s'installer et pas forcément libéral pas
forcément libéral derrière ils peuvent
avoir une activité professionnelle au
choix en fonction de leur choix il
n'empêche que c'est une allée de
professionnalisation tout à fait
importante et qui mérite peut-être
monsieur que le ministre qu'on se penche
sur les deux cycles précédents pour
faire une année de moins parce que 10
ans c'est long et on résumerait
tout le monde y gagnerait merci chers
collègues la parole
à Monsieur Chassain
monsieur le ministre madame la
Présidente
oui tout d'abord je voudrais
concernant le rapport de l'amendement de
Bernard Chaumier je voulais dire que
effectivement dans l'objet il résume
bien ce qui est
est la portée de cette proposition de
loi et en fait bon il exprime à la fin
la nécessité de payer davantage donc les
les étudiants en quatrième année moi j'y
suis favorable j'ai proposé tout à
l'heure mais ça ce sera voir en dans un
deuxième temps avec les étudiants il est
évident qu'après 10 ans on ne peut pas
les payer à 2000 euros par mois c'est
surtout leur gros problème quand on
parle avec eux si vous voulez et puis je
pense que il faut alors j'avais proposé
moi dit consultations par par jour parce
que lorsque un médecin qui a une
clientèle qui oui qui est surbooké il va
faire appel à un jeune médecin mais il
pourra lui donner facilement 10
consultations par jour et être là au cas
où il y a un problème pour le conseiller
et
si vous voulez également dire que les ne
plus parler de désert médicaux par les
deux jeunes soudains mais il faut quand
même que les médecins sont là pour
soigner ils sont là pour aller dans des
endroits où on a besoin d'eux c'est leur
vocation ici ils ont fait médecine pour
ça donc je ne vois pas quel est le
problème de demander un an pour des
médecins pour des jeunes médecins à
aller dans des zones où il
a besoin d'eux je ne vois pas quel est
le problème et la plupart sont d'accord
c'est un problème de rémunération
bien merci après cette intervention la
présidente Catherine de roche et ensuite
je pense qu'on passera au vote sur
l'amendement merci monsieur le Président
je voulais parler de cette place de
cette pppl dans la loi mais je rappelle
qu'en 2019 on avait mis quelque chose
dans la loi pour pour la troisième année
et demain nous allons voter proposition
de loi pour les sages-femmes sur lequel
votre groupe est en effet moteur et très
porteur on touche en effet parfois
lorsque la formation des professionnels
de santé demain ce seront les
sages-femmes c'est vrai que le cursus
est différent de celui des médecins mais
c'est quelque chose que l'on fait que
l'on fait régulièrement et puis je
voulais dire bon je sais ce qui a été le
travail de commission d'aménagement du
territoire depuis des années sur ce
sujet moi quand j'étais conseiller
régional à la demande du président
Retailleau j'avais fait le plan santé de
la région des Pays de la Loire en 2015
dans le cas de la commission aménagement
du territoire de la région donc on est
sur l'amén du territoire mais ce que je
veux dire c'est qu'il n'y a pas
opposition de la commission des affaires
sociales les autres commissions comme si
on faisait affaires sociales nous sommes
tous des élus locaux nous connaissons
nos territoires nous savons en effet ce
qui s'y passe et c'est pas du tout une
opposition entre commissions sur ce
sujet-là bon après qu'on soit pour ou
contre la coercition c'est un vrai sujet
moi je n'y suis pas favorable parce que
je pense que c'est pas une solution
partout elle a été faite ça n'a pas
marché partout elle a été faite ça n'a
pas marché lisez lisez le le rapport
c'est le rapport qu'on a eu de
benchmarking sur sur ce de pardon
de Madame poltron sur le sujet partout
on est on arrive de Suède avec la
commission des affaires sociales je peux
vous dire qu'ils ont les mêmes problèmes
d'attractivité pour les professionnels
de santé que ce soit les médecins et les
ou les paramédicaux ils ont les mêmes
problèmes que nous donc c'est avec un
système totalement différent donc je
voulais quand même préciser ceci bien
merci nous allons passer au vote donc
sur l'amendement je rappelle qu'il y a
deux avis défavorables de la Commission
et du gouvernement donc qui est pour cet
amendement
qui est contre
qui s'abstient
n'est pas adopté ensuite deux
amendements
identiques qui font l'objet d'une
discussion commune le premier
présenté par Madame Gerbault
merci monsieur le Président cet
amendement propose d'affecter les
étudiants de 4e année en priorité dans
une zone de sous densité médicale située
dans la région à laquelle appartient à
la subdivision territoriale de leur
faculté de formation le but de ce
fléchage et d'éviter un phénomène
d'appel d'air incitant les étudiants
d'un territoire régional donné à
délaissé ce territoire au profit
d'autres zones soudances malgré tout
plus attractive à leurs yeux en d'autres
termes nous souhaitons éviter que les
territoires de rattachement naturel des
stagiaires ne se trouve spolier du
maintien sur place de leurs étudiants
par l'attraction relative de texte
secteur objectivement moins défavorisés
donc amendement identique monsieur
Chassin
Président mes chers collègues c'est un
peu dans la même philosophie c'est un
moment propose que les étudiants en
dernière année d'internat qui effectue
leur stage dans le territoire où ils ont
réalisé leurs études ils doivent
effectuer par énormément que le
territoire qui forme des médecins
puissent bénéficier des forces vives
parce que effectivement dans ce
territoire
les étudiants viennent de des fois de
territoire très éloignés et je pense que
ils doivent rester pour leur dernière
année dans le territoire cela permettra
également une meilleure répartition des
internes sur les territoires de plus
c'est une réponse supplémentaire donc à
l'objectif initial de la proposition de
loi savoir lutter contre les zones
Soudanes
si donc Madame la rapporteur avis de la
commission sur ces deux amendements
ces amendements favorisent tous les deux
l'affectation des stagiaires de 4e année
de médecine générale dans la région du
centre hospitalier dont il relève je
comprend l'intention des auteurs qui est
d'éviter que les internes qui étudient
dans une faculté de médecine délaisse le
territoire où ils sont étudiants
il pouvait cela pouvait présenter au
départ des difficultés parce que si le
nombre de maîtres de stage n'est pas
toujours proportionné localement à la
population des internes il fallait
pouvoir que ces étudiants exercent dans
une autre région à défaut de pouvoir le
faire dans la leur les amendements 3 et
8 qui ont tous les deux été rectifiés
par leurs auteurs pour tenir compte de
ces difficultés permettent désormais des
exceptions et exclut aucun territoire en
conséquence la commission a aimé être
favorable sur ces deux amendements
avis du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre
Michel Président Mesdames et sénatrices
monsieur et sénateur madame la séatrice
Goulet je vous remercie d'avoir corrigé
mon lapsus non révélateur bien entendu
je suis un inconditionnel de la
concertation et je suis fermement opposé
à la coercition
madame la sénatrice Gerbault monsieur le
sénateur Chassin l'affectation des
internes se fait déjà dans la
subdivision territoriale de leur faculté
inscrire ces dispositions dans la loi
c'est par ailleurs se priver d'une
éventuelle souplesse pour autoriser des
exceptions utiles à certains territoires
en particulier des territoires qui sont
limitrophes entre deux territoires de
facultés enfin la répartition des postes
d'interne n'est pas décidé seulement par
le ministère de l'enseignement supérieur
de la recherche mais conjointement avec
le ministère de la santé et de la
prévention en tenant compte des besoins
de santé des territoires
pour toutes ces raisons je suis
défavorable à votre amendement car déjà
satisfait par les textes existants
bien merci donc nous allons passer au
vote si j'ai pas de demande
d'intervention avec un avis défavorable
de du gouvernement et un avis favorable
de la commission donc et pour l'adoption
de ces deux amendements
qui est contre
qui s'abstient ils sont adoptés
ensuite l'amendement 13 rectifiée
monsieur Savary
oui merci on a déjà abordé ce problème
de la rémunération de cette quatrième
année donc je vous propose là de faire
une dérogation ou décret existants parce
que tout le monde la souligné il faut
trouver une rémunération à la hauteur de
la formation de de ces jeunes faut pas
mettre à mal non plus la rémunération
actuelle des médecins spécialistes c'est
pour ça que au départ il était préconisé
de rémunération à l'acte mais ça
engendre des effets dominos
difficilement maîtrisables tandis que là
en faisant une dérogation par rapport au
décret qui a été pris ça me permet
d'avoir une rémunération hauteur alors
je trouve ça extraordinaire
de pouvoir proposer ça sans avoir
l'article 40
je m'en félicite puisque c'est une
dépense supplémentaire alors que j'avais
proposé alors que j'avais proposé
alors que j'avais proposé de diminuer
une année
dans les deux premières des années des
deux premiers cycles
pour que cette quatrième année de
troisième cycle reste
à 9 ans en tout pour pas allonger une
année qu'elle soit pas contre-productif
mais là j'ai été article 40 une année de
moi ça génère des dépenses
supplémentaires mais une réponse
supplémentaire ce ne sont pas posée de
problème donc je soutiens bien sûr cet
amendement et je vous invite je vous
invite à en faire autant
avis de la commission
le président monsieur le ministre je
rappelle juste que l'article 40 et
décidé par la commission des finances
non mais c'est pas la commission des
affaires sociales qui s'auto on est
d'accord quand même
des contraintes pour revenir sur
l'amendement qui demande en fait qu'un
décret soit publié des contraintes
spécifiques s'appliquant aux étudiants
de 4e année de médecine générale
auxquelles il est demandé de faire un
effort de réaliser des stages en
exercice ambulatoire en zone soudain il
est normal que leurs conditions de
rémunération puisse être adaptées les
étudiants devront être justement
rétribués au regard du travail qu'il
fourniront et de la contribution qu'ils
apporteront à l'accès aux soins de nos
concitoyens gouvernement doit avancer
sur ce sujet ces prochains mois en
concertation avec l'ensemble et j'ai
bien dit en concertation avec l'ensemble
des parties prenantes la commission donc
formulée un avis favorable sur cette
amendement
c'est le président mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs et sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Savary je comprends
le souhait de trouver une rémunération
la plus adaptée à cette quatrième année
du Diplôme d'Études spécialisée de
médecine générale c'est justement l'un
des objets de la mission que nous avons
mis en place avec Madame la mise de
l'Enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche dont les conclusions sont
attendues pour le premier trimestre 2023
je souhaite que ce sujet puisse être
travaillé dans la concertation avec
l'ensemble des parties prenantes en
prenant le temps nécessaire à son
instruction en particulier vu
l'incidence cela pourrait avoir sur les
autres spécialités médicales pour toutes
ces raisons je vous demande de retirer
cet amendement
bien monsieur Savary l'amendement est
maintenue j'imagine
vous maintenez l'amendement puisque il y
a une demande de retrait du gouvernement
donc je vous pose la question vous
maintenez l'amendement
allez-y allez-y
pour répondre à votre question monsieur
le Président
ça ne m'a pas échappé monsieur le
ministre que vous lanciez une
concertation
il n'empêche que quel que soit le
résultat de la concertation vous serez
amené à prendre une dérogation par
rapport au décret donc autant être
concret autant montrer votre ouverture à
une rémunération descente de ces
internes en quatrième année de de
dernier cycle c'est la raison pour
laquelle monsieur le Président je
maintiens bien entendu cet amendement
c'est entendu c'est noté monsieur
Richard
monsieur le Président Monsieur Miss mes
chers collègue moi je voterais
naturellement cet amendement parce que
je les consigné et parce qu'il est
apparu très clairement tout au long du
débat que c'était une condition vraiment
essentielle au fonctionnement de cette
démarche présentée par la proposition de
loi du président Retailleau mais
permettez-moi juste de revenir sur
l'article 40 je sais bien que c'est pas
la compétence de la commission des
affaires sociales comme l'a fait tout à
l'heure monsieur Sueur sur l'article 45
il y a dans cette maison un vrai
problème avec ses limitations aux droits
d'amendement
là on a quand même là prenez Paul on a
quand même là l'illustration claire des
dérives liées à l'utilisation de cet
article 40 lorsque j'ai consigné cet
amendement chez René Paul je me suis dit
je vais le consigner mais attention à
l'article 40 je me suis dit il a aucune
chance de passer il passe il passe mais
l'autre mais l'autre avant de demander
que j'avais consigné aussi passe pas et
là aussi il y avait l'article 40 donc
franchement je sais j'ai déjà demandé ça
ici dans cette salle plusieurs fois on
m'a envoyé un fasculé extraordinairement
long complexe élaboré par la commission
des finances sur l'article 40 j'avoue
que j'y comprends toujours rien mais là
ça vaut vraiment le cas ça aurait la
peine de regarder très clairement
comment on a pu à la fois appliquer ce
fascicule encore une fois et puis arrivé
à ces aberrations signalées par René
Paul Savary vraiment je le redemande une
nouvelle fois examinons cette affaire
des des des articles limitants
clairement le droit d'amendement c'est
la torial
madame à pourri
monsieur le Président écoutez les
questions qui sont posées sur la
rémunération prouve s'il en était la
limite de la proposition de loi qui nous
est proposée on nous propose donc on
propose de mettre une dixième année sans
avoir consulté sur la rémunération on
nous parle d'une rémunération à l'acte
mais alors qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça
veut dire ces jeunes vont être
volontaires pour aller dans une zone
soudain il y en a qui toucheront cinq
acacte par jour d'autres en toucheront
10 d'autres en toucheront 15 d'autres 25
il n'y a pas de cadre et donc on va
créer des inégalités entre les jeunes
même vous dites non mais si parce que
ils seront payés à l'acte donc ça veut
dire qu'on va créer pour un même boulot
des jeunes qu'on envoie en soudance qui
ne toucheront pas la même chose je
trouve ça complètement scandaleux et
c'est en ça qu'on voit la limite de
votre proposition de loi
bien merci monsieur
merci monsieur le Président simplement
je voulais apporter une réponse à notre
collègue concernant la rémunération dans
le texte dans la proposition qui est
faite c'est une dérogation donc ça
laisse le temps à la fois de la
concertation entre les étudiants et
gouvernements de façon à ce que à la
fois répondre aux attentes portées par
ce texte de loi mais en même temps et
bien aux attentes portés par les
étudiants voilà donc on a le temps de
discuter et d'avoir quelque chose de
cohérent sur le territoire national
ok bien nous allons nous allons monsieur
Chassin oui après nous allons passer au
vote sur l'amendement
je vais répondre à ma collègue
en libéral moi j'avais proposé qu'on
puisse donner aux internes de 4e année
10 consultations minimum mais il est
évident que vous savez quand on est en
libérale il y a des jours on fait
beaucoup plus de consultations d'autres
moins c'est comme ça ce qu'on est en
libéral et il s'agit pas de dire que il
y a une discrimination de tel ou tel
étudiant je pense que oui le médecin
qui aura besoin d'un interne de médecin
junior et bien il aura une clientèle
bien sûr parce que s'il en a pas besoin
il en prendra pas il aura une besoin
d'une clientèle il aura besoin de
médecins junior parce qu'il a une
clientèle où il est complètement débordé
et avec le médecin junior il pourra
arriver à la fois à le conseiller et à
la fois de faire du bon travail et voilà
et je pense que c'est des proposition je
pense que 10 consultations par jour
lorsqu'on travaillait cinq jours par
semaine ça fait 5000 euros par mois
voilà
alors nous allons passer au vote avec
une un avis défavorable du gouvernement
en habit favorable de la commission sur
cette amendement qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient il est adopté avant de
passer à l'examen du dernier amendement
je veux juste signaler que nous sommes
j'ai été saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public par le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen écologiste et par le
groupe les républicains donc chacun peut
se préparer dans les groupes à ce
scrutin public sur l'article oui demande
de scrutin public sur l'article donc
dernière amendement sur cet article
madame bellurault
merci président d'abord je voudrais
remercier mes collègues qu'on consigné
cet amendement vous avez dit monsieur le
ministre que vous souhaitez des
solutions concrètes et pragmatiques et
bien c'est amendement va pouvoir vous
combler en effet c'est amendement a pour
objet de dire quoi de dire que des
médecins retraités puissent être médecin
référent pourquoi parce que cela a été
dit il y aura une difficulté d'avoir des
médecins référents en nombre et puis il
y a dans nos territoires et dans
beaucoup de nos communes plus de
médecins dans des communes moi j'ai été
lu en 2014 maire d'une commune de 2000
habitants Reilly dans l'Indre j'avais
deux médecins généralistes et un
chirurgien-dentiste aujourd'hui il n'y
en a plus aucun demain si nous ne
prévoyons pas la possibilité pour que
ces médecins viennent accompagner ces
étudiants et c'est tout à fait normal
qui puissent être supervisé et
accompagnés si nous n'avons pas la
possibilité d'avoir l'expérience de ces
hommes et les femmes qui sont dans
beaucoup de nos communes toujours est
présent et qui sont prêts à aider à
l'installation prêt à accompagner ces
jeunes étudiants ou ces jeunes médecins
et bien nous n'aurons jamais de médecins
nous n'aurons jamais ces jeunes dans nos
communes très concrètement parce que on
nous dira ah vous auriez pu avoir un
médecin junior mais c'est pas de chance
vous n'avez plus de médecin alors vous
n'aurez personne il faut que demain et
je sais que ça relève du domaine
réglementaire j'en suis bien consciente
mais vous savez comme moi que les débats
sont là aussi pour éclairer la rédaction
des décrets pour éventuellement aussi
éclairer les contentieux possibles mais
je souhaite monsieur avec cet amendement
d'appel je vous fais donc un appel dites
moi monsieur le ministre que il sera
possible à des médecins retraités demain
d'être des référents dans ce cadre là il
faut l'organiser ça peut être des
médecins qui sont à la retraite depuis
moins d'un an depuis moins de 5 ans je
vous dis ou 10 ans je ne sais pas mais
en tout cas il nous faut aujourd'hui le
prévoir sinon ça ne fonctionne pas
chers collègues la réforme de points
réussir que si elle garantit un
véritable accompagnement aux internes et
améliore leur formation je pense que
nous sommes tous d'accord sur ce point
elle doit permettre aux étudiants de
médecine générale de découvrir
l'exercice ambulatoire en cabinet ou en
structure d'exercices coordonnées aux
côtés de Praticien en mesure de les
accompagner dans l'appréhension de
l'autonomie sur ce point l'ouverture de
la maîtrise de stage à des médecins
retraités je parle bien le médecin
retraités qui n'exercerait plus
risquerait d'envoyer un mauvais signal
aux étudiants la maîtrise de stage est
déjà ouverte au médecin en cumul emploi
retraite je tenais à le rappeler le
gouvernement doit pouvoir accélérer le
recrutement de maître de stage en
exercice ils sont aujourd'hui à peu près
12000 y compris et surtout en zone
soudance pour permettre la pleine
réussite de cette réforme leur nombre a
déjà beaucoup augmenté cette dernière
année et de nombreuses collectivités
s'emploi à favoriser la formation des
maîtres de stage dans tous les
territoires je pense particulièrement au
conseil départemental de la
Charente-Maritime qui a avec Accor de la
Faculté de médecine de poitiers
favoriser l'organisation des formations
pour les maîtres de stage au plus près
de leur lieu d'exercices dans les
départements où il y a pas la Faculté de
Médecine je pense que c'est important
alors on en a discuté avec notre
collègue mais pour ces raisons machin
collègue je vous demande de retirer
votre votre amendement j'ai bien compris
que c'était un amendement d'appel à
défaut la commission a émis un avis des
favorable monsieur le ministre
même avis monsieur le Président mais ma
vie
madame belureau madame belureau vous
avez une double demande de retrait
j'ai entendu notre collègue rapporteur
et je vais le retirer mais je souhaite
si vous le reprenez vous le reprenez
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
concrètement je sais qu'il y a un cumul
emploi retraite et que l'on peut à ce
moment-là mais il faut que on comprenait
bien que au moment de la rédaction des
décrets c'est une chose que je connais
un peu très vite on va évacuer cela et
ce n'est pas possible vous n'arriverez
pas cette réforme et nous n'aurons pas
de médecin junior dans nos territoires
si nous n'avons pas la possibilité
d'avoir l'expérience de ces hommes et
ces femmes qui sont prêts à venir aider
dans des communes où il n'y a plus de
médecins donc il faut vraiment que il
soit possible qu'il soit agréés qu'il
soit agréés parce que demain il faut pas
venir nous dire ah écouter c'est dommage
on peut pas les agréer parce qu'ils sont
plus médecins ça fait un petit peu
longtemps
voilà je comprends que les jeunes
puissent se dire qu'il faut peut-être
des actifs mais moi je peux vous dire
j'ai des hommes et des femmes qui ont
été médecin dans ma commune qui sont
hyper compétents qui seront parfaitement
guidés en plus la patientèle il la
connaissent et ils sont de bonne volonté
et ils sont compétents et ils peuvent
encore aider ce que nous avons besoin il
s'agit de la vie d'hommes et de femmes
aujourd'hui et de leur santé donc je
veux bien le retirer mais je mais que
mes collègues le reprennent donc
je ne peux vous dire que ça je me suis
engagée à cela mais si un des
consignataires voilà merci donc madame
belureau a retiré l'amendement donc nous
allons passer maintenant au vote sur
l'article je rappelle que j'ai été saisi
d'une demande de scrutin public par les
groupes CRCE et les républicains sur cet
article unique et qui va être procédé au
scrutin public dans les conditions
fixées par l'article 56 du règlement
le scrutin est ouvert
bien le scrutin est clos
le nombre de votants 344 les exprimer
328 pour 233 contre 95 l'amendement est
adopté
l'article pardon l'article est adopté il
nous reste un amendement
après l'article unique monsieur sol vous
présentez
bien monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues dans un contexte de crise
c'est amendement André a inscrire le
fait que le rapport de la part des
étudiants se destinant à la médecine
générale en troisième cycle devrait être
inversé je propose donc la part des
étudiants en médecine générale en
troisième cycle soit supérieur à la part
dédiée aux spécialités
dans une proportion de 70%
30%. une telle mesure concourrée je
pense à lutter contre la pénurie
médicale et rejoindrez l'objet de la
proposition de loi je vous remercie
avis de la commission madame la
rapporteur
la
médecine elle concentre environ 40% des
étudiants accédant au troisième cycle
sont recrutement augmente chaque année
plus de 100 étudiants par exemple
supplémentaires en 2022 par rapport à
l'année précédente en prévoyant que la
médecine générale devra concentrer à
compter du premier janvier 2025 au plus
tard 70% des postes ouverts aux
étudiants de 3e site cet amendement
risque de placer les autres spécialités
dans la difficulté la médecine d'urgence
la réanimation ou la gynécologie
obstétrique par exemple ne sont la
pédiatrie bien sûr madame la Présidente
ne sont pas moins essentielles à l'axe
soin de nos concitoyens c'est pourquoi
la Commission a formulé sur cet
amendement un avis défavorable
même avis défavorable mais ma vie donc
un double avis défavorable vous
maintenez l'amendement monsieur sol
j'y crois donc je le maintiens merci
donc nous allons passer au vote sur cet
amendement
madame de la propreté excusez-moi je
vous avais pas vu
oui je suis défavorable parce que là on
parle des médecins généralistes mais en
difficulté gynécologie obstétrique je
vous signale juste que c'est juste un
problème alors ça concerne les femmes on
est d'accord mais quand même c'est un
vrai sujet en ophtalmologie c'est un
sujet on anesthésie réanimation c'est un
sujet aussi dans un certain type de
chirurgies on est aussi en déficit de
présence dans les territoires donc on
peut pas déshabiller l'un pour habiller
l'autre on a besoin de tous les types de
médecins on a besoin de grossir
globalement les promos de faire les
choses plus vite et mieux et c'est vrai
que il y a une comment dire une
complicité je peux le dire comme ça
collectif pour avoir pendant des années
pas formé assez de médecins et puis
remettons les ces parce qu'après tout
les médecins généralistes qui sont bons
dans plein de domaines qui sont
polyvalents qu'il redeviennent
gynécologue médicaux qu'il redevienne
cardiologue de ville enfin bref on a
tout fait pour manquer et de
spécialistes et manquait de généraliste
donc je pense que sur la portion congrue
qui nous est proposé dans les effectifs
de l'internat ne mangez pas
pas la part des autres je vous remercie
bien donc nous allons passer au vote sur
l'amendement donc avec deux avis
défavorables qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient l'amendement n'est pas
adopté donc on va passer aux demandes
d'explication de vote sur l'ensemble de
la proposition de loi je signale que je
suis également saisi d'une demande de
scrutin public sur l'ensemble de la
proposition de loi donc vous pouvez
également vous préparer donc je passe la
parole à notre collègue à l'un ou père
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre mesdames les rapporteurs
cette proposition de loi
pose une bonne question sur la
démographie médicale
mais apporte-t-elle une bonne réponse
je ne pense pas que ce soit une bonne
réponse
parce que en médecine on traite toujours
la cause et on traite pas la cause et la
cause des déserts médicaux dont on ne
peut pas parler
c'est l'aménagement du territoire qui a
toujours été un peu pieux on en a
beaucoup parlé mais on en a jamais fait
il n'y aurait pas de désert médicaux
s'ils les territoires étaient plus
attractifs et si les banlieues étaient
plus sûr
déplacer un étudiant pour un stage de 4e
année dans un territoire défavorisé
c'est délocaliser déplacer une famille
pendant un an c'est déplacer le conjoint
c'est trouver des logements trouver des
écoles trouver des garderies trouver des
collèges trouver des lycées et trouver
des moyens de culture à des gens qui ont
été pendant dix années dans
université en milieu urbain souvent on
explique que les étudiants en médecine
sont favorisés parce que
l'État leur a payé leur médecine mais le
sénateur ozulias a fait de l'archéologie
et un merveilleux aisément expliqué que
les médecins remboursaient leur dette en
renforçant l'hôpital et le remboursait
largement donc
choisir un maître de stage c'est
difficile de choisir un maître de stage
c'est un spécialiste peuvent choisir un
maître de stage les médecins
généralistes ne peuvent pas renforçons
latravité d'attractivité des territoires
et ne faisons pas un service médical à
l'instar du service militaire que
certains ont connu et arrêtons d'embêter
les étudiants en médecine merci
merci chers collègues la parole est à
Hervé Moret
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre mais mes
chers collègues je voterai cette
proposition de loi qui est une des 16
propositions qui figuraient dans le
rapport que nous avons commis et que
Jean-Luc fiché il y a 10 ans et qui
s'appelait désert médicaux agir vraiment
c'était il y a 10 ans et malheureusement
depuis on n'a pas vraiment agi et les
choses n'ont pas beaucoup bougé et je me
souviens de Madame Bachelot à ce banc au
moment de la discussion sur la loi qui
porte son nom qui nous expliquait que
c'était un mauvais moment à passer et
que dans 10 ans tout ça serait arrangé
malheureusement on est 10 ans après et
les choses n'ont fait que s'agrange que
s'aggravait donc je voterai ce cette
proposition de loi elle sera
certainement adoptée mais sera-t-elle
appliquée il y a nous de nombreux
exemples de dispositifs qui ont été
votés en la matière à commencer par le
dispositif dont on a parlé tout à
l'heure de la loi de 2019 qui prévoyait
un stage obligatoire à partir d'octobre
2021 le décret n'ont jamais a été pris
donc à quoi ça sert de voter des
dispositifs si ensuite ils ne sont pas
appliqués mais je suis aussi convaincu
et je ne surprendrai pas grand monde
dans cette hémicycle que l'on ne réglera
pas le problème avec ce seul dispositif
et je demeure convaincu qu'il faudra je
le disais déjà il y a plus de 10 ans un
jour installé une régulation en
installation et la régulation ça n'est
pas la coercition nous l'avons fait en
France avec un certain nombre de
professions de santé notamment pour les
kinésithérapeutes avec des des succès
qui ont été reconnus ça se fait dans de
nombreux pays je ne vais pas développer
parce que je vois que le temps est
extrêmement conté mais je crois que face
à l'échec patant parce que personne ne
peut contester l'échec des politiques
mises en place depuis bientôt 30 ans qui
reposent uniquement sur l'incitatif et
bien il faudra un jour que l'on ait des
gouvernements courageux pour oser
déplaire aux médecins parce que je
comprends tout à fait ce qui a été dit
sur les médecins sur la difficulté de
leurs études j'ai moi-même une fille
médecin mais je crois qu'il y a quelque
chose encore plus important que le
confort des médecins c'est l'accès des
patients à une médecine de qualité
la parole à Nathalie Goulet
comme mon collègue Hervé Moret lorsque
nous avons dans cette hémicycle voter la
loi Hôpital Patient Santé territoire il
y avait une disposition un peu
coercitive il a fallu qu'elle inversait
quelques mois après dépose une
proposition de loi pour supprimer un de
l'article qui était un peu coercitif au
motif que ça avait provoqué une Broca
chez chez les médecins donc moi je
voterai aussi évidemment cette
proposition parce que le sujet est
évidemment plus qu'un irritant dans les
territoires ruraux et dans les zones
évidemment
dépourvu de médecins et que ce soit les
banlieues des grandes villes où les
territoires ruraux que cette accès est
extrêmement important mais je trouve
qu'il est dommage que le débat se limite
à la quatrième année que ce soit
seulement le 15 novembre qu'on est un
débat sur parcoursup parce qu'en réalité
la filière elle est aussi bloquée à
l'entrée c'est aussi un échec de
parcoursup
de démobiliser un certain nombre
d'étudiants qui voudraient être médecin
qui ne fonctionnent pas donc je crois
qu'on a saucissonné le débat sur la
quatrième année sur le sujet qui nous
importe aujourd'hui mais j'ai quand même
le sentiment madame la présidente des
roches que le débat qui aura lieu ici le
15 novembre sur parcoursup répondra en
partie si on arrivait à débloquer cette
situation pour avoir plus d'étudiants en
médecine sachant que l'ensemble de nos
territoires et c'est pas mon collègue
Vincent Segoin a qui n'est plus là qui
me démentira le D ah il a changé de
place voilà le département de l'ordre
comme d'autres départements se sont mis
à salarié les médecins pour essayer de
pallier les manques et donc tout le
monde fait beaucoup d'efforts c'est un
sujet éminemment important pour chacun
d'entre nous encore faut-il le prendre
dans le bon sens certes la proposition
de Monsieur Retailleau est intéressante
mais je crois que tant qu'on aura pas
réglé aussi le problème de l'entrée dans
la filière et donc parcoursup on aura
des problèmes donc rendez-vous le 15
novembre sur le débat sur parcoursup
merci la parole à Alain Milon
oui merci Monsieur paysan je voulais moi
revenir sur la loi ma santé 2022 qui
avait été proposé à l'époque par Agnès
Buzin et dont j'étais rapporteur et je
me souviens d'un amendement qui avait
été présenté par corinabert qui
proposait que la troisième année de
spécialisation soit une année justement
qui permettait aux étudiants de partir à
l'extérieur et de se former dans les
cabinets médicaux les étudiants à
l'époque nous avaient dit une chose
assez extraordinaire c'est qu'ils
estimaient que cette troisième année ne
pouvait pas le faire à l'extérieur parce
qu'ils étaient insuffisamment formés
j'ai des témoins ici qui ont assisté à
cette réunion dans la mesure où ils
étaient insuffisamment formés on a
décidé de passer à 6 mois ce qui a été
voté en CMP par l'Assemblée nationale et
par le Sénat et jamais appliquer par le
gouvernement cette fois-ci donc on leur
permet de faire une formation complète
pendant trois ans puisqu'il souhaitait
cette formation complète il la feront
mais ils font une formation en milieu
hospitalier c'est à dire qu'ils
apprennent à soigner les maladies le
diabète attention etc etc mais ce qui
est intéressant dans ta proposition qui
est faite par pour une retaillaux c'est
qu'en plus on leur propose d'aller
travailler avec des médecins sur le
terrain et d'entrer en contact non pas
avec les maladies mais avec des patients
ce qui est pas du tout la même chose
soigner quelqu'un en cabinet en
individuel ou soigner quelqu'un sur un
lit avec un chef de clinique un interne
un patron ça n'est pas du tout la même
chose donc il est extrêmement
intéressant que nos étudiants puissent
faire cette quatrième année d'autant
plus que lorsqu'ils ont jusqu'à présent
lorsqu'ils ont terminé leur troisième
année seul 30%
30%, s'installer définitivement et
immédiatement les autres attendaient
faisaient des remplacements etc cette
fois-ci on aura l'intégralité des
étudiants en médecine générale qui iront
chez un médecin généraliste qui
termineront leur formation au contact
direct patient et pendant ce temps-là
prépareront le docteur donc c'est une
c'est une proposition de loi qui est
extrêmement intéressante c'est que je
vous appelle à voter
il reste encore deux explications de
vote ensuite je vous propose qu'on passe
au vote sur l'ensemble du texte donc
Daniel Chassain
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je voterai
mon groupe votre aussi cette proposition
de loi bon d'abord je voudrais dire que
dans les dans la ruralité il y a aussi
de la culture il y a aussi des écoles il
y a aussi des des collèges même des
lycées pas très loin bon c'est vrai que
il y a pas d'université mais surtout il
y a souvent pas d'emplois pour le
conjoint et ça c'est vrai que c'est
difficile parce que maintenant il y a
quand même une grande féminisation de la
médecine et mais les jeunes hommes aussi
ne souhaitent pas travailler
24 heures sur 24 et
mais maintenant ça complètement évolué
il y a beaucoup moins de garde et
maintenant la vie en rurale et tout à
fait compatible avec
de vie que souhaite avoir les jeunes
donc nous avions voté avec président
million une un projet de loi qui allait
dans ce sens en 2019 bon ça il n'y a pas
eu de décret mais actuellement ça s'est
encore beaucoup aggravé et les mères
nous demandent absolument dans nos
départements dans nos cantons de d'avoir
quelque chose d'efficace non pas pour on
va pas punir les internes on leur
demande mais bien sûr ça a été dit il
faudra qu'ils aient un salaire décent
parce qu'ils ont fait 10 ans et c'est
normal que au bout et bien il puisse
avoir un salaire des temps pour faire
pour faire vivre leur famille mais on
leur demande simplement pendant
pendant
après pendant cette quatrième année
d'apporter ce qui est souhaitable
c'est-à-dire apporter la médecine dans
tous les secteurs de notre pays et je
pense que c'est ce qu'il faut faire je
pense que cette loi va permettre
d'amélioration donc je voterai cette loi
la parole à Daniel Bruyer
chers collègues monsieur le ministre
monsieur le Président un mot pour dire
que si cette PPL évoque des sujets
importants elle passe à côté d'un examen
en profondeur des mesures qui seraient
nécessaires pour à la fois améliorer la
formation des jeunes médecins et
également répondre aux enjeux difficiles
du manque de couverture médicale dans
beaucoup de territoires au fond cette
ppel est un contourne les sujets
essentiels de la nécessité ou pas de
mesure de coercition de la question des
formations initiales de la nécessité de
concertation avant de légiférer et notre
groupe est favorable sur ces sujets
comme sur d'autres à ce que la
concertation précède la loi et pas ce
qu'elle la suive c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous voterons contre cette
proposition de loi
merci Madame la rapporteur
après le vote donc nous allons passer au
vote je vais mettre au voile l'ensemble
de la proposition de loi donc je j'ai
été saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public par le groupe les républicains il
va être procédé au scrutin public dans
les conditions
fixées par l'article 56 du règlement le
scrutin est ouvert
bien le scrutin est clos
votant 345 exprimé 328 pour 232 contre
96 la proposition de loi a été adoptée
je vais suspendre la séance
pardon pardon excusez-moi avant de
suspendre la séance la parole à la
rapporteur Corinne Imbert
merci Monsieur le Ministre merci pour
votre écoute et pour votre avis de
sagesse sur cette proposition de loi
merci mes chers collègues pour la
qualité de nos échanges et merci à
l'administrateur pour m'avoir accompagné
sur ce texte juste cette proposition de
loi du président Retailleau n'avait pas
n'a pas la prétention de de tout régler
mais il était important qu'elle soit
votée aujourd'hui
la situation actuelle en matière d'axo
souhaite insupportable pour un grand
nombre de patients les tous un portable
pour les élus et il fallait apporter une
première réponse c'est un pas ça
n'enlève pas d'interne à l'hôpital
public bien au contraire peut-être que
le renfort et l'arrivée de docteur
junior dans les territoires évitera
évitera l'arrivée aux urgences de
patients parce qu'ils auraient été
prises par un médecin en ville on parle
toujours du lien ville hôpital
ira mieux si la médecine de ville va
mieux c'est un pas un pas demandé aux
internes en médecine générale bien
évidemment un pas demandé au ministère
en terme en termes de connaissance un
pas demandé aux médecins généralistes
installés pour demander qu'il devienne
maître de stage un pas demandé à la
faculté pour faciliter la maîtrise de
stage au plus au plus près de lieu
d'exercices je pense que c'est tout
l'intérêt de ses propositions de loi
donc merci à vous de l'avoir voté
bien merci donc je vais suspendre la
séance pour quelques instants afin de
permettre à chacun de s'installer pour
le prochain point à l'ordre du jour nous
avons pris du retard il reste encore un
texte avant la coupure un autre ce soir
donc
s'il vous plaît faisons le changement
dans le plus rapidement possible